what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
first of all y'all Happy Thanksgiving
um as you guys know I started this show
eight months ago and I am thankful for
each and every one of you
um thank you so much for helping me get
to where I'm at
um okay a couple announcements before we
start the show the first is that we have
two clips channels the first is just
Pearl eclipse and the second is Pearl
daily go subscribe to both of those we
have two different editors on those
accounts to give you guys a little bit
different editing Styles so um go
subscribe to both also guys um if you
want to be a part of the live chat today
make sure you sign up for the first tier
it's only five dollars and it helps us
support things like our rent blessings
new monopod
um lighting updates and just different
um Studio updates so it's really
important that we have um members the
second here is you get to be a part of
our Discord and our behind the scenes
blogs you guys may not know this but I
am a rapper so if you guys are away
if you guys want to see me freestyle rap
you have to join our second tier and um
you get to see me in one of our Vlogs
freestyle rapping
third tier you get to connect with me on
social media that means
to my inbox um fourth tier you get a
get along with me once a month if you've
ever wanted to start a live show like
this I can help you avoid a lot of
problems that I had early on and make
your life a lot easier so if you have
any questions about how to start a live
show I really recommend that tier also
guys they took away my Instagram again
no just the first one it's just like I'm
still building it back up you're still
sad about it yeah I just haven't I would
be too yeah yeah I mean I'm a woman we
can't live without Instagram anyways
um go follow my new one new one it's
just pearly things one um also guys they
took away my first four tick tocks so um
follow my new tick tock
justperlythings.5 and six
um also guys thank you for 730 000 Subs
we just hit that today
I feel like we just hit 700k so it's
crazy how fast we're moving um if you
guys want to come on the show make sure
you DM the pregame show also I'm gonna
start doing a behind the scenes
reactions so basically I'm gonna have
like friends over you know like denalva
we might come react to like maybe maybe
we'll freestyle together or something
I'll try a thing I think you'll outdo me
though
for the culture so if you guys want to
see just like behind the scenes looks
with show guests um the new reaction
Channel we're starting go to my
community post it's the last Community
post the link to that is on that
Community post also we have wife school
so if are you at 304 are you a modern
woman that wants to be a wife we boy do
I have actually girl do I have do I have
the school for you so um we're gonna be
bringing in wives from across the
country married to high value men that
are going to teach you how to catch a
high value man and how to be a wife
um so if you want to know that um
subscribe to that channel and you can
watch me and other girls go through the
Journey of a modern woman to wife so
also also
today are going towards blessings
monopod all right blessing is there
anything else you want
no okay okay you don't scare me
blessing loves to buy new things
anyways guys so if you guys want to see
more Studio updates up up you know up
the quality we're already shooting an 8K
for video reaction so make sure all
super chats are going towards um Studio
updates okay so well done wow okay it's
up to you so today we have a lovely
panel um so why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status let's add where
you're from today and a fun fact about
yourself so starting there and then go
around and then we'll do second row
um my name is Valentina I'm 19 years old
and I'm Russian and Nigerian
and a fun fact about me
um I have a cat
were you born in London um yeah I was
born no I was born in Gillingham
somewhere in Kent a small little place
okay okay random but yeah
um my name's harabella I'm 19 and I was
born in Essex I'm so bad at the fun
facts thing like on the spot
um
do you have a job yeah I'm a model okay
and a sugar baby
sometimes
are you accepting applications like it's
not nobody guy wants to apply no ignore
the minute someone's got my eyes
[Music]
I'm I'm South London and I'm an erotic
novelist
did you get any of it let's start again
again okay so I'm Naomi Alexander I'm
35. I live in South London and I'm an
erotic romance novelist oh that's so
interesting like 50 Shades of Gray type
stuff
um it's spicier spicier than that yeah
that was tame
what the what's what's past they do like
everything in that not really
[Music]
and where are you from from I'm half
Nigerian and half British okay go ahead
um I'm Claudia I'm 25 I'm married and
I'm polish
um fun fact
oh gosh again that's a hard one yeah
um
most people think I came here as a baby
but I'm really fresh off the boat so I
came as a teenager oh
what was that me yeah my name is Elson
I'm 26.
um I was born in Portugal families from
like Mozambique
um fun fact about me
um cake boxer I've been doing that since
I was like 16 years old
me
hey guys my name is Alexander 27 based
in North London uh Finsbury Park and fun
fact about me
is
I
really like to snowboard
you want to go
hi everybody she's back
follow me on the gram denalva dot
a-o-d-i-n-a-l-v-a-a dot a o
um I am 29. I am single I am angolan
Portuguese so my brother is there Alison
nice to meet you and the fun fact
and obviously I speak English
yo your boy it's your boy and those tdmb
the lady's favorite as you don't know
um I'm from West London
fun fact about me
let me give you a different fun fact I
can do the Rubik's Cube in a minute and
45 seconds
yeah that's that's cool can you teach me
yeah there's a method to it it's easy
I'll teach you Pete don't worry
I've always wanted I feel like I would
look so smart
when I do it on the Train sometimes like
people are Bamboozled like yeah it's
like they're like what I just think
that'd be a really good like party trick
yeah I went to Harvard not really but I
couldn't I could do the reviews it's
algorithm that's it
okay all right last but not least my
name is kdot I'm from West London I'm
from Jamaica and Grenada
I do music and a fun fact about me
whether it's boring Vibes or Good Vibes
I'm always alive for the party facts
facts if you know you know I can vouch
for that oh yeah fun fact that handles a
little brother yeah that's my little
brother
a family tree right you better not cause
me trouble you know I'm like never never
okay be careful with the novel I thought
okay
um so today's topic
drum roll
I don't know how okay
women can't be hoes forever
oh yeah I mean okay okay so so question
for the women and remember you don't
have to answer if you don't want to have
you ever had a whole face and how long
did it last
I don't think I'm out and I'm joking
well I can't really answer that question
I've been with my husband for nine years
where is your husband
[Laughter]
for sure appreciate it appreciate it I
mean could you not hoe it together
pardon could you not have hoed it
together
I'm not a fan of Sharon and I know that
she's the same so to be fair we thought
it would keep it simpler and just be us
soon just [ __ ] do it
that's cute
yeah what about you guys ever had a
whole face
um I attempted to and then I realized
it's just not for me
um
yeah that's pretty much it I don't want
to say anymore
can I ask how long it lasted because it
sounds like not that long
um it lasted for about two months but I
feel like it's not for the week
no yeah like I've attempted to before
but I just I think I've fallen in love
too easily with people
and also I don't like that feeling of
like being used or like someone's only
like interested in you sexually I think
that's so like ill excited
sugar baby yeah I mean I mean it's good
it's good for money but but isn't that
like multiple people yeah but it's more
online the way I do it oh okay so no
physical yeah like usually they're from
America and they're just real desperate
to talk to like a girl and yeah it's
like Andrew Tates like girls type stuff
yeah they were just like talking yeah
literally like giving them false hope
giving them false promises oh so you're
manipulating people to take that money
is that what you say I'm like no like
I'm just capitalizing
that's exactly what it is
exactly okay
I would never do it with someone I
genuinely like like money is not
something that impresses me but if
someone's gonna give it to me um
yeah I'm not gonna be like No [ __ ] I'm
trying to get paid
I know someone that I worked with that
Snell stopped working and she's she does
um she's like a Dominatrix and she she
does like pay picks something like that
yeah that's literally it
you literally just called empathetic put
them down and it gets them off and you
hit them as well
during my life with my life and she's
like I'll ruin you like send me your
savings
the girl that I know they actually asked
they asked that they actually asked her
to record them as they withdraw money
from their ATM yeah and um and she'll be
like a good boy those are the men that
do exist hiding in the closet I'm just
saying
um
being on this panel I'll let you know so
you try to help a short period of time
yeah I mean I did it like I did like my
one little hookup or whatever and I was
just like it wasn't even like anything
deep I literally yeah like a little
touch and I just didn't like that
feeling of
Beignets and I didn't I wasn't getting
money in return so yeah it was pointless
would you if you were getting money in
return or Greece would it have been
different
now I don't mind being I can't do for
money but you just said if if it was
touching then it would have been okay so
that isn't just eye candy that is
exchange of money I guess I wouldn't
like have sex for money but I definitely
I don't know if someone was like kind of
like touch up give you a mess I've been
paid for a massage before okay getting
my skills in London know how to be eye
candy especially if you've been to like
Mayfair clubs I mean I used to be a
promoter when I was like 18 19. and as
much as I felt bad for saying to the
girls like you know you're a bit
you know you're not gonna get in or
she's your friend's gonna have to pay
at the same time it's like you kind of
understand that you have all these
footballers and all these celebrities
and Rich business people paying 10 15
grand for a table why does their Club
differ from anyone else in Camden where
you can just walk in and not pay that
much so you have to do for some harness
you have to accept your account eye
candy at that point because you're going
in for free you're drinking is that a
whole phase though it would be an eye
candy isn't a whole face yeah not really
when I was younger I'm still young but
so wait pull your mic closer and let's
just yeah go ahead I know you guys are
sharing something hard um when I was
younger would I have called it a hoe
phase no was I open to exploring and did
I date yes and so I guess other people
may have seen that as a whole phase but
I didn't see it as a whole face I was
exploring and also when you go to buy a
car you try out all the cars first you
don't just pick the first car well
except
I'm a Gemini so I ain't never gonna pick
the first car I need to try it
I mean I just I'm not very good at
choosing one thing straight away and
sticking to that one thing in that
moment and just being like okay I'll
have that kind of pop and that's even if
I got into the shop to buy a packet of
crisps it takes me a minute so how long
did uh the kind of whole face it sounds
like you're not you're hesitant to call
it a whole face but yeah because I don't
like to label why should we label it I
mean
why to describe it I think everyone has
a whole face yeah yeah well yeah um how
long did it last
um
well I was in a nine-year relationship
with my son's dad so it stopped then and
then it started again and then it
stopped then it started again I think in
between relationships like where I've
been like like total how much time would
you say a year total maybe like two
three months between yeah something like
that yeah we'll go with that two years
yeah hook up with that okay
in the 35 years I've been on this Earth
a year okay over the year okay de novel
what about you
I haven't had a whole face I've been
mostly in relationships almost back to
back I have experience but no never been
a hoe it's the same reason but that's
the same as not labeling it as a heart
like you've experienced I experience
being like in total I've been in
relationships for about
10 years and I've only been single for
just a year so that's crazy
do you know what I think P
what do you think I think that if you
are not this lady right here with a ring
on her finger you're stuck in the whole
face forever and until you get around
wait wait wait wait wait and it's in her
face can I just I'm so sorry to do this
in her face are we talking sleeping with
men or are we saying it doesn't matter
because I've never met him even though I
was young I was 15 I was seeing loads of
guys at the same time I mean I didn't do
anything with him I didn't even hold
hands with them yeah but I was
continuously talking to loads of guys
this is what I'm saying but the thing
with me was it was from a young age even
like when I was seven my first boyfriend
I broke up with him because he had bad
grades you know when I was best friend
but like to cut to go back to like no
point is that the whole phase exists
that's your like as a single woman that
is your mission to get out of that area
in my eyes because if you're single you
can access the whole face anytime you
like like women have the power to be at
home minding their business and they can
just pull out their Rolodex and call
somebody and they know somebody 100
that's the same thing as you saying that
every man has the capability to kill
that for every man is a murderer that's
so yeah and you know what Jordan
Peterson says the same thing a dangerous
man is a good man a weak man isn't a
good man you want a man to be able to be
dangerous but control it that's what
makes a great mess that's why a woman is
not a hoe because when she is
controlling her she's not at home
wouldn't you say that if a woman's
acting like a hoe she's a hoe yeah but
just because you're someone doesn't mean
you're a hoe I I didn't say nobody said
that no what he said that's what he said
as long as you're sick
what he was saying is is every woman as
we know we all have options we all have
options right so what he's saying is at
any given time I have the option to be
like you know what I want to [ __ ] so I'm
gonna press this thing and Power Ranger
man is Gonna Come Through that's what he
was saying so in his mind it's like if
you're single you have the potential to
be in that whole face yeah everybody has
a potential I think okay I think I
understand so you're basically saying
like you might as well be a hoe because
you have the option too and you're never
gonna know yeah and that's up to you and
women have that freedom because we as
like I said as we as men we would never
ever know wait wait can I just jump in
yeah would you say that is the option or
the power too because those are two very
different things I mean well she and she
has the option to exert that power true
yeah
I put a spin on it it's just because I
feel like if you're gonna go down that
whole path that's very different than
just having the options kind of dip your
toe in every once in a while yeah you
got the option not that either one is
good or yeah I hate what you're saying
but then it falls into that like
language where it would fall under
Dayton OH I'm dating again you see what
I'm saying so it depends on the
intention and where you're doing it from
but that's why I also but that's why I
ask what we mean by hoofers because if
we mean by her face that someone's
sleeping been around because if you're
going on a date and then on the second
date you're sleeping with someone I
would say that's a whole phase but if
you're you're going on a date and you're
like actually on a second one you know I
don't feel that I'm gonna go on the next
day and the next day and the next day
yeah
so I have a question for the girls did
anyone feel like they got anything out
of the whole face like a positive
experience
what I did get out of it was
understanding myself and what I did want
and what I didn't want from like because
there's one thing being in a long-term
relationship I've been in long-term
relationships like my son's dad nine
years my last relationship for three
years I got a lot from them but what you
get out of it like quite quickly is like
your icks your dislikes your okay I'm
not gonna do that I don't actually like
that type of guy or I don't I I maybe
don't Vibe with this type of person so I
got a lot from that do you think that
whole phases make women more picky
[Music]
100 because then you can go through men
quite quickly and be like nothing I
don't want to say do you think whole
phases make women less attached yes yeah
I don't have a yes or one million
percent so I don't know about that
actually actually I was on on my Endo
speaking to one of my best friends and
um she's slept with a few guys and she's
in a relationship but she and I and I
kind of speak to her about you know like
she we have a mutual understanding of we
don't kind of
you don't judge enough yeah don't judge
her for being a hoe okay
it's like with many guys
lit like it's still under 10 like way
less under 10 but it's not one like me
do you know what I mean so for her and I
said to her you know the flags
I speak to her about like power bonding
and stuff like that and she she said you
know we have a very under a very uh
respectful relationship where we allow
each other to fulfill our points and
she'll just say you know what even
though I'm in a relationship because
I've slept with more guys I love my
boyfriend but I can imagine not being
with him I can you know imagine
drifting away and because little things
piss me off
listen can I ask you a question no you
know if me and him break up if we
divorce I'm going into deep rooted
depression I'm losing my job I'm moving
back in my parents I can't imagine right
because I don't I'm not looking I don't
I can't even comprehend do you think
that's healthy though to be that
attached that bonded to somebody that
you don't like your end of your you
being an individual being on this planet
on this Earth yeah is so rooted in
somebody else's existence that if they
died oh even though if they died never
went over extreme there if you went if
you weren't together anymore that you
would then Lose Yourself
that sounds beautiful
that sounds scary
it is it is scary I'll tell you because
it's scary because I mean I have a dog
that we have a dog that's five years old
and I know she's gonna die in 10 years
and I will literally cry every day
knowing that she's gonna die before me
but with him it's completely different
and it's like yeah I can understand how
some people can see that as like a
insecurity or like no no no no no not
insecure no but like some people
security or codependence and stuff like
that but I I think we I can I hope I can
speak for the two of us
um that we choose to live our life
together as individuals we are very very
different people
um and I think we we
you know we we choose to live together
but
can I ask you can I do you think yeah
that the reason why you feel that way is
because you come from a different world
because you did say you came when you as
a team you see your friend that you're
talking about was she born here yeah
yeah she's she's English here and this
is why men are going to the East and
finding wives
I always hear it yeah they're actually
all the dating coaches say to go to
Poland
to buy a fries
it's not it's not to buy a bride it's
just like they have more feminine
traditional women that tend to be in
shape and pretty apparently I've never
been to Poland yeah I mean I I grew up
going to school and you know women would
be walking to school in high heels
makeup ready yeah like I've been to
Germany which it's not Poland but but
it's like compared to America and even
here the girls are like 10 times
prettier like I was in Russia I went to
a wedding I was like oh my God like they
would blow everyone here out of the
world but does makeup and heels high
heels Define femininity no no I'm not
naturally about the thing there is there
is a standard that they want to keep up
they will always want to represent their
men it's not it's not it's a sense of
vanity the same way there are Latin
women dressed in a certain way and they
have a certain standard of beauty and I
do understand actually when you look to
certain extremities of the world you do
see femininity in more in like higher
levels it's good for some people it's
not good for some people do you
understand what I mean because actually
when we look at these countries that
have this sort of thing realistically
economically they are suffering in
different ways which means that we need
to look at the society we have issues
here but there's also certain way that
we work that helps us actually survive
that's corruption that's why things are
kind of messed up still but I say bring
shame back in fact I've said that all
the time really you know it isn't that
one of the reasons why men kill
themselves because they're ashamed that
they're in cells
that's not the reason
back sorry that's terrible
I think men should be shame for not
getting laid you should try to get laid
off
so then so then like this is what I find
that is interesting because obviously
shame is such a low vibration it's
terrible I think what's going on with
the in the world now and everybody's
starting concerned is that they don't
understand everybody's suffering
mentally this is not about bringing
shame it's about yourself no everybody
needs to be told the tools to be strong
you don't need shame to be strong
yeah
wait wait wait you absolutely do need
shame to be strong you do because it's
like if your mom yells at you you learn
not to do something like okay I'll give
you an example I was overweight and then
you know
I'm just wait the guys at work were
saying like oh I would never date a girl
over 200 pounds and I just hit two like
205 or something and I was like
the shame helped me but it's like you
could either be a weak person and let
shame break you or you can be a strong
person and let it motivate you okay let
me give you an alternative that is one
of them you can shame somebody but you
could also say you know what
you could be so much more beautiful if
you're healthier you know try something
like that yeah
if that works then America wouldn't have
a I can't say that anymore an obesity
issue because genuinely no
denalva people genuinely mean like the
body positivity that's huge in America
we're huge it's not much better here you
guys are much less obesity no no because
then that's what I'm saying do you know
why we're not why people hear more obese
actually is because they're not taught
how to be better to themselves for
example I'm Portuguese I know listen my
diet listen the diet the the things that
people miseducated all the time the food
here is discussing I'm not gonna lie I
come from Portugal I know the difference
between the population then the
population here it's all because of
miseducation we are not taught to tell
people to have the tools to
independently growth that's an excuse me
in 2022 there is no excuse you have
access to the internet yeah I can type
in a YouTube video and get the world's
best nutritionist giving me a video on
nutrition and it's pretty much much
Common Sense fruits vegetables common
sense is not common but at the same time
if you've been programmed from Deep like
reprogramming your brain to eat a
different way it is hard work so as a
lazy Society we're all lazy that's why
we like to watch Quick gratification is
a thing it's easy to press
I come from a country of Pokemon
potatoes
yeah
one at one at a time one at a time we're
not we're not doing the over talking
then go ahead go ahead my family
put on like five kilos like my
metabolism but I make conscious
decisions and I mean I reckon if I lived
in Poland I'd probably be stick thin I I
probably would it wouldn't you know be
going to the gym and trying to grow my
legs and so forth I'd be trying to be as
skinny as possible but you know I chose
a partner that's in the gym industry and
he teaches me certain things other
things I'll Google myself because he
can't teach me about you know woman's
nutrition it's it's all about
accountability and making your own
choices and when I said earlier just
coming back to my point because I I
never finished it I think there's a
difference between shame and bullying I
think it's different when you point out
to people oh you should be doing this
because you're fat you're ugly I don't
think we need that as a society I just
think that yourself you should be able
to look at yourself and see and be
realistic and you know I mean in this
country people go to freaking Asda in
slippers and pajamas and then get back
into their own bed in those clothes I
mean I I but even that is it's not right
for me right do you want to put your
best football forward no matter where
you go no I definitely think the world
needs like bullying
yeah
if you ask anyone that's actually
successful they'll tell you the reason
for their successes is their most
negative parts of their life within
doesn't teach anybody anything when you
lose it motivates you to win like now in
school they're doing like no first
second third place in school you know
school um Sports days you're not
teaching children to win like the guy
who's the fastest doesn't feel special
now because the guy who's the slowest
got the same medal as him you should
know that he's the slowest so there's a
gap that now everything's kind of all
Blurred Lines there's no definitive kind
of clear winner and everybody wants to
be the winner but they don't actually
have the ability all the skills to be
the winner so it's like you need
somebody to come and ruffle feathers a
little bit in the military that's what
they do they break you down I was in the
military for six years and they
literally they break you down they like
for you better mattress out the window
your [ __ ] you this is to make you the
best that you can possibly be so I I
agree with it on some sides of things
but at the same time there's a line I'd
also like to add it always always seems
like this aversion to negative
um feedback is always kind of
it's always behind a goal to make people
less competitive I've never heard
someone say oh we shouldn't be negative
because it will make you better it's
always kind of like to placate at best
I've never heard anyone you know
coaching someone or trying to reach for
excellent and say actually let's not
let's not tell you what's bad about
yourself because you might stop working
hard and I just think that's quite
interesting that at best you're trying
to play cake I think that's in a really
interesting point especially in um
between females we're always told don't
compare yourself don't ever look at
another woman I mean I personally think
like how do you know know if you're
doing good or not if you're not
comparing yourself I mean my mom never
compared me to other people but it was
like
well you know
um you got an A and she got a nice start
well it's like if you don't compare the
world will for you yeah the world isn't
blind he sits down it's like you you
know and I always say like you know when
you walk into a room with your friends
you know who your prettiest friend is
100
um you know but can I ask you a question
pretty girls always know it's dumb
and I'll have these conversations like
there's a girl I'm thinking of on my
team and I was explaining this Dirk she
was like what her beauty standards blah
blah blah and I'm just like okay are you
prettier than so and so and then she
starts laughing and then I'm like okay
why are you laughing
yeah go ahead I wouldn't say that
there's an issue with comparing it's
good to compare so you can Benchmark I
think there's a problem with shaming for
sure because even when you look at
sports the best the best like the
Champions everyone's like who's the best
who's the best who's gonna get this good
because you need no because what we need
is encouragement when you're a kid and
you're growing up actually when your
parents encourages when you do the best
because as you want to when you want to
be better you want because it's positive
positive reinforcement is actually way
more powerful than negative
reinforcement and that's it and this is
the thing we start to act like adults
and not just children in big bodies we
all have our inner child that actually
the more you keep giving negativities
the more we're going to go into
ourselves and be depressed
I think I think the best teachers are
the ones that didn't put up with [ __ ]
like there's a teacher I had in seventh
grade who I swear I got a team in my
life of living hell but I could still
tell you how to diagram an English
sentence better than anyone this is a
shame but did you when you did something
well even though like if you weren't if
you weren't listening or you weren't
doing something you were meant to do she
would be strict but then when you did
something well did she praise you or did
she tell you did she just ignore the
fact that you were I mean I should go
because then because then when you look
she was kind of a was it like validation
like my son like when he like his she
knew she knew how to make you chase her
value exactly and that's exactly what it
is it's like I give you well there's
barely any
you drip feed the validation isn't it
isn't it that's kind of weird though
like you're trying to you're trying to
manipulate them into being great yeah to
chase positive kind of validation so
what's the difference I had some strict
teachers
um I used to live right next to my high
school and I have a problem I used to
have a problem with punctuality so I was
two minutes away from my school but I'd
always be about 30 seconds late right or
like 10 seconds like I was never on time
I was always lasting and she would give
me the detention if even if I was like
five seconds late and this happened for
weeks and I had detention after the
tension I was like yo I'm literally you
just closed the door I put my hand you
crushed my hand I'm here on time and she
would be like no but she when I was on
time she didn't congratulate me hey
because she knows I'm asking dude I
don't give I don't care what you think
I'm B I think it's because she
understood that it's not exceptional to
do what you're supposed to do and I
think that's that should be the
mentality of that you should coach kids
to be fit for society not to chase
validation or oh you know if I tell you
something good they're gonna work harder
I don't think most people work like that
but doing a basic I agree don't give
over don't over praise somebody for a
basic but if you achieve have an actual
achievement just say you won an award
would we all clap but wait no one's ever
clap for me no because well you don't
have us around you then do you because
we would clap
do you know what an award is for
exceptional yeah but that's what we're
that's what we're striving for now yeah
I mean you would think but I think now
we give awards for being average
because if you ask like if I go on the
street rate yourself one to ten with
what like a lot of women when I go on
the street I'm a tan tan I'm a teen
yeah remember one to ten I get called
Rihanna all the time
if I had her money maybe
so that so that means you're adjustable
seven then I said humble 8.5 that's
humble 8.5 hmm
it's hard to be humble over seven
baby I know I'm working with you just
own it the novel you know I just say it
I'm an 8.5 a humble 8.5
can I just ask are you when you say 8.5
do you say um just because of your look
so the whole planet
actually no I'll say probably looks
whole package nine whole package nine
and and if you want to just say looks
eight one five
yeah yeah
okay at five I think you think you're in
the top 15 of beauty why aren't you in
Hollywood where are your modeling
contracts my modeling contracts are not
there because I'm not trying to be a
model they find you no but I don't want
to find people
no she's a model well yeah like I've
literally
um like just gone from posting on
Instagram and stuff
um I like have been offered to work for
Bottega and puma and like collaborations
with like Dua Lipa just from like
posting on Instagram that they do they
have just found me naturally but also
like when I've applied I always get like
replies I sound so [ __ ] big-headed
but like I do I like I applied for
Willamina like yesterday and like this
is like one of the biggest modern like
things in the world I do feel big-headed
now like they replied but it's results
so basically you're prettier than me
because you're a model and I'm not wow
no I don't think that I think beauty is
I'm saying results mean something but
they don't I'm I'm saying I do these are
subjective isn't it I found it it's very
subjective I do agree with you because
beauty is so subjective like one person
might look at me and then be like [ __ ]
like you're sorry but one person will be
like no I think no matter what I think
there is certain things
um you can look at someone even if
they're different no matter what race
they are no matter what
um what texture their hair is no matter
um you know how they behave their
confidence you can look at a person even
like someone like you and I I mean we
differ so much and someone would say
okay she's better looking than this
person right because no I think like
yeah because you've got to remember
there's a general consensus for beauty
that's been going on for a hundred years
no no I think you can just look at
someone and say sure people that love it
like prefer obese people for example
they're certain names
looking and being a model or to like
being a model you have to have a certain
standard because they they're going to
put you as a face of their brand yeah
and being pretty is another thing so
yeah you need a symmetrical fate Like
Girls Just symmetry that's what I'm
saying like people that are model level
pretty get model level results yeah I've
never posted an Instagram photo and had
a modeling agency reach out to me but I
don't think it's crazy like top 15 of
beauty that's a lot that's really really
amazing Beauty on symmetry is very
dangerous because Beauty does not
actually no that's the standards based
on what people are trying to tell you
just because wait wait wait don't know
it's not just symmetry it's also your
weight yep okay
with blue eyes
scientifically when you look at somebody
if somebody's face is symmetrical
automatically your brain is
dopamine in your brain and you're like
oh she's beautiful
exactly so it's not just there look and
you could even do like dating app data
like you know behind the scenes if you
have a dating app it ranks you one to
ten yeah so like behind this seems like
you have a rating and and it sounds good
yeah it's what are your matches look
like that's your rating what they look
like yeah yeah yeah because that's what
I bet you did so so like top top five
percent or two percent of guys get get
top 10 a girl or something like that or
top 20 percent of girls whatever so they
have to filter and so what you have to
filter when you get them all I think
it'd be very different to what people
write themselves go ahead go ahead
what'd you say I just think it'd be very
different to what specifically women
rate themselves oh yeah yeah I mean I
mean we're told from a young age we're
special you're princesses
I don't understand why women don't
understand I don't understand why women
don't realize that men controlled rating
the same way you guys control the rating
for us we control the rating for you and
you know always trying to pick your own
rating can we just be sitting there
thinking what is going on
he's fightful yeah got no money he broke
he broke [ __ ] he should never stand
next to me Ray is next to me oh no he
smells you don't smell nice you don't
make it ratings these are all ratings
yeah we don't even give you that much
ratings man her face when all that but
she got a fat ass cool like matter cool
real nice food you look we're actually
quite easy the second we start going in
you don't have standards so how can you
raise them
you just took the words out of my mouth
because the second I go into standards
you like lose your mind but who do you
think you are what do you bring to the
table I'm like yo I just wanted my milk
my breakfast made in the morning I want
you to say good morning to me and be
nice
when you go into like standards and very
firm objective kind of levels I know
it's a lot of a lot of women I know go
into this whole like post-modern like
but what is beauty everyone's kind of
beautiful it's like the Lions start
getting blurred I want to play Oh I want
to play a game
so so instead of hmm I want to say who
does anyone hear a thin skin everyone
with thick skin here okay okay because I
don't I don't want anyone to cry
all right okay okay so I want everyone
all right first to start rate yourself
one to ten
it looks wise yeah it looks wise just
looks
eight eight okay yeah I'd say I eight
six six six six
eight point five nine is a whole package
okay what do you rate yourself is I
usually say five maybe okay anyways
anyways
um
now now I want the guys to hurt the
girls
so she's she's a she's a 10 but minus 10
because she's my man's wife in it okay
okay
um spiritual lady how do you know I'm
spiritual because you got a weird
necklace on with shapes
he's talking about like your star sign
and like challenging generals stuff like
that
um
I'm gonna stop it the first one actually
now you gotta rate everybody okay
four
uh
three
ow my lucky enough
also also I don't I don't know you so
personality is like three points
now we're just going based on looks but
just looks
I'm not that's everything
that gets another Point yeah
whose guy is it yeah he's harsh he's
harsh I mean not except for me thank you
[Laughter]
too you too you don't want to do it
right I'm out tonight
because she's a wife you could you could
no honestly I'm fine it's up to you guys
you can pick it's okay you don't have to
participate if you don't want to
participate I don't go ahead okay what
does handling I'm just curious how
people women and then I'm gonna have the
women rate each other too
oh [ __ ]
um right I'm gonna start with the novel
the novel
[Music]
um tell me I'm ready I'm gonna give the
novel an adjustable seven ah look at
that and adjustable what does adjustable
mean so so you know so you know
depending on what she says on a
particular time
like on a normal day you know fresh face
no makeup I'll say a seven but she you
know when she gets you know spruced up
you know she could get that eight nine
in there maybe it's an adjustable one uh
let me go from
yeah yeah
um what's your name sorry me yeah
Valentino Valentina oh that name might
have just given you an extra point
s
6.5
Valentino is like oh it's a nice name
um in the middle here
um
based on what I'm looking at right now I
don't know because I did say you just
came from a shoot so I mean I don't have
like Foundation or not yeah so I'm gonna
just say five and call it a say five
okay yes say five you know
um
Naomi
rabbit
[Laughter]
yeah exactly
I'm not friends with people we're not
friends what we are friends we're
acquaintances of course like you're my
peoples and you're my brethren in it my
brother that's what I'm saying yeah it's
love but you know being friends with
females is tough
um
let's not get into it
um Naomi I'll give a Naomi a
[Music]
7.5
yes yes
I think that's 7.5
and
that was tense yes it was
um
no no I'm gonna nah nah I'm gonna
continue man I'm gonna rate everybody on
the panel
um
based on based on the information that I
have received so far
she gets a nine
and the reason why she gets a nine
because one she has a ring so that
automatically just puts Five Points
right
[Laughter]
um and um what you were saying about how
you would go into like a just just the
kind of honest devotion that you've
given to your husband and the respect
that you've given him and told him like
even if he wasn't here my [ __ ] would be
messed up that's that nine that's that
nine that's a nine bro so bro let's
celebrate love oh my God it's so cute
yeah all right what about you all right
respectfully I won't even rate his wife
that doesn't I have no respect
I'm joking I won't meet his wife I'll
give Naomi a solid eight
yeah I'll give
sorry what's your name the blonde one
sorry
Bella I'll give you a uh I'll give you a
solid five and a half
and I'll give your friend six
and I'll give you a solid eight
see what I'm saying
quick and simple okay another question
no no question question for the girls so
okay the girls have to close your eyes
close your eyes close your eyes close
your eyes I'll say I like this okay okay
um
so if you open your eyes you're gonna be
subbed out yeah oh yeah there's a sub
there's a so you'll be subbed out if you
open your eyes all right
um from the couch on the left you guys
remember where everyone's sitting oh
yeah yeah yeah so I was on I would cover
I'm sorry I I forgot some of your names
I won't lie to you but polish girl all
right all right put your hand up for how
what you rate her
fingers
okay wait so now we have to put your
hand up oh oh close your closer wait
wait wait wait did she put up in her
eyes
okay okay now um next to her with the
the tattoos yeah Naomi put your hands up
okay
um but I'm sorry I'm so sorry about it
okay
with a height okay keep my eyes closed
yeah eyes closed eyes closed eyes closed
this is so stressful okay okay and then
right what's the question the other
rating one to ten wait who are we on uh
Arabella with a h
with your rate in the novel you're
supposed to put your fingers up with
what you're rating
you close your eyes
close your eyes Okay and rate how much
you think the other girls look the
number with your fingers
the blonde girl on the couch the blonde
girl on the couch okay
I haven't read today I thought you were
asking people to open their eyes Okay
Okay
um you had a very pretty name but I
don't remember what it was Valentina
Valentina Valentina
um everyone go
um
okay dinamo what do you put for
Valentina put your hands up okay wait oh
my God
please
okay now everyone do denalva
okay okay thank you guys that's it
that's it nobody didn't do the rest I
didn't do the rest are we allowed to
open up yeah you can open your eyes it's
just interesting I just it's interesting
to see what the men put the women put
and then like what you guys put
this back guys
all right
um let's ask the tough questions today
how many bodies does it take for a woman
to become a hoe
yeah
I want to start with the men and then
the woman can answer how many bodies
yeah how many bodies does it take as in
like uh high level men or bodies yeah I
thought you said Bodies Okay
um
in my experience
Sun changes after like
three people I know
oh if she slept with three people that
you've actually yeah
so I don't know I don't I don't have an
opinion for you know women before that
but when I meet someone or like you know
they come into the same scene as me Etc
if she's been with
more than
to put more than two people but
definitely three then that's like
because so you're saying like you're
never gonna know the actual body count
so you kind of Base it by the number of
dudes that you know that she's slept
with yeah so if you find out about three
then she's a hoe it's how you conduct
yourself yeah if that's if I know two or
three guys in the room if I know two of
you guys in the general scene in London
that you've been with then it's um
because it's too much of a small walk so
you've been about no I'm about about no
the girl the girl if the girls had three
men that you know that means she's been
about to go all the way to the three
that you know in your life The
Coincidence also my boys are some of the
top guys in it so if if you've been with
one of my boys then I know
you know where you at yeah yeah
where's your head at type vibes okay
what about you
[ __ ] his wife's got one so is it two
you know what I'll be a little bit more
generous on that front maybe I'll say
when you hit the double double figures
yeah okay what about you
uh I'll maybe say when you roughly hit
above maybe over seven but then then
again some girls
be dating a lot but they're not really
hurting but they'll be dating and
hopeless Romantics will fall in love and
you know what I'm saying and then
they'll add up so as he said like yeah
when it starts to reaching 9 10 then
it's like yeah you just
okay so 9 10 what about you
so mine is kind of like age condition so
if you're like in your 20s and you're
over 10 yeah you're done if you hit 30
and you're over 15 yes okay speak so you
say 15 by 30 times before okay ladies
what do you guys think how many bodies
does it take for a girl to become a hoe
um yeah I'll agree with you I think it's
like very age conditioned but I do think
like
I don't know because I know some people
like I think it's like a double digits
yeah that's when you like become a high
I think a hoe can reform
yeah
Rehabilitation
but then like oh this is kind of
embarrassing to admit but like I'm only
19. my I've never [ __ ] before like
I've still never been [ __ ] I'm still a
virgin I don't think that's embarrassing
obviously I've obviously done like stuff
we've got as nine guys to like count
um but people would still call me at
home because I like post-provocative or
like I think it's just very subjective
on what you think I hope it is like I
have people call me a hoe every day
because I like post half naked but I've
actually never been [ __ ] before and
like all my hoe in is like I've done
like online stuff and whatever but yeah
there's levels the whole window so
that's what I will say there's there's
levels you know you can get an escort
that's gonna do everything you can get
escort that's going to talk to you on
the phone like there's levels I mean one
level is language right so
if you refer to yourself as like being
[ __ ]
I'm very I'm very like confused or like
made lava yeah you want to use one of
the nice words you know
there's a whole language right there
I'm just really directly sorry
what about uh you two haven't answered
yet
um I'm kind of like where I've forgotten
your name Alex Alex says
um like if I don't know then like who am
I to call you a hoe you know and
like I would probably say double digits
maybe but then I know friends that are
in double digits and I'm like I love
them so it's like as always people it's
humans
they could be a nice hole
but why would I call it but for me
but for me to use that language towards
somebody for me in that moment like I
can't say that I love somebody and call
them a hoe like it doesn't come in the
same sentence so like to me you're just
experienced life to its fullest right
yeah I can't I can't call you a hoe and
then say I love you like they don't come
in the same sentence I wouldn't call
someone a hoe full stop
to be fair like I have a very different
definition of a hoe because I I think of
a whole someone who's who who sleeps
around carelessly yeah consciously oh
yeah yeah I think I think someone who
sleeps in unconsciously whether they've
slept with 10 you know 20 people
whatever I mean after after a point it's
like it's hard to consciously sleep with
like 40 people but you know that that's
that's how I think of it so close to me
have an energy it's a spiritual Vibe
it's like that's Tendencies
William Tantra they exchange energy on
so many different levels with people and
it's not classed as being a hoe like you
are there's no penetration energy but
for some people if you're touching so
like I'm a tantric practitioner and we
like we get taught how to do certain
things to people and it's not about and
you can give that service but would you
then class me as well like I don't do
that by the way but I mean for some
tantric practitioners but it's not
called our a prostitute or a horror
because I mean it's very very very
conscious and it's a massive exchange of
energy that can be you can manifest you
can do something for women not for men I
mean Metals sleep with goddamn anything
anyhow
that you just said that you
um I
gave that to somebody because for me I
would I need to be really trusting of
somebody to get to that point of
intimacy to that level because I as much
as I'm very out there with my thoughts
and opinions me exchanging energy with
you I understand the level of energy
that I am able to give and so I can't
just touch somebody I know how to do it
but I yeah you just don't I just don't
choose to yeah I was gonna say then it
means that in in a way because it's
conscious you exactly you knowingly
don't want to be exchanging energy with
so many people yeah so in a way it will
take a certain type of person to do you
take a hole to do that [ __ ] exactly well
I was getting out of my brother you got
it all right I got you bro how many how
many bodies is Too Many Bodies too
well what the hell how many I think
I
think
friends
but you can tell my friends they're at
home if they've slept over 15 people
I'll be like you at home but I love you
[ __ ] okay 15. yeah I think if I feel
like if you're uh my age 25 and you've
slept over 15 then it's like
yeah
you must have gone gone through a dark
path something must have happened yeah
you've been streeting absolutely and
back to what you were saying I do think
people nowadays don't think sex is like
a big deal like it is a big deal like
for me to especially for a woman like
for me to let someone inside of me that
is literally so personal that is so like
that should only be shared with someone
I genuinely really care about you guys
can come out and wash their dick in
there please like actually letting
someone inside this is the same as like
you're becoming a part of me basically
yeah for that period of time not a
period of Time Forever DNA yes when a
man goes inside of you then your soul
connected DNA is inside you for life
you're you're connected to that person
on a soul level it's not just oh yeah I
can you can do lots of rituals but at
the same time that's why girls that do
sleep around you can there
what do you what do you mean their DNA
is that well when somebody comes inside
you to be graphic like that's okay just
use condoms then
at the same time not everybody is using
condoms that's why there's so many
questions someone's body is actually
entering yours no I'm just saying in
terms of the DNA thing for the rest of
your life on an energetic level on an
energetic level wrap it up still
exchanging energy with somebody so it's
like yeah you can wrap it up but I mean
energy isn't just inside this physical
thing yeah just Triton around uh what
about you denava oh it's not really a
word as in my vocabulary
therefore
I would say
that
word
wait how is the female version of a simp
where you are eaten and you don't eat
that's it which means that if you're a
woman yeah and you're being used by men
because you are insecure because that's
when you're going to be likely to be
labeled a hoe you know what I'm saying
whereas I believe in sexual Freedom
which means that you shouldn't be
labeled anything for wanting to be with
a man I have my name you see me because
I don't have a husband please give me a
number
it depends it depends it depends like
for example I know women that step with
five men that'd be like actually do you
know what you're kind of loose but then
I know that people that slept with five
men that actually I'm like you know what
I understand why you do this part okay
all right five a hoe or not a hoe yes
please yes it depends on the person okay
okay 50. you're talking about my teacher
please
I think she's maybe damaged okay
okay let's use the word damaged and
everyone else this means hell yeah
damage damaged is she damaged at 10.
depends on her intentions okay so maybe
uh maybe not 15 is she damaged depends
on her intentions okay when does it
switch to yes
so when she's letting men go 20 is she
damaged
depends on her intentions okay 30 is she
damaged
I just want to know when it switches out
um let's say 30 by 30. under what
conditions how many were boyfriends
okay you know what for [ __ ] to give
girls let's say half were boyfriends
then nah what if she was having
threesomes with her boyfriend how does
that change because if you have an open
if you're in a relationship for a long
long time maybe you want to open that
stuff
I think anyone that does an open
relationship that like that's hopeless
I believe in sexual Liberation it
doesn't mean that you need to be labeled
all it means is how you feel about the
action that you're doing so I don't like
it I don't think there's anything
liberating for sex with women there is a
woman a woman has needs you really think
that woman yeah
but you can get your needs met by a
boyfriend or a husband yeah and that's
what I'm saying so sex is not really
what you should look on your mind how is
it liberating to sleep around and not
call someone a hug no it is liberating
to be able to choose to have sex when
have we ever not been able to choose
listener and that's what I'm saying
no there's a difference though no
because this is the thing as a woman if
you are not able to make a choice yet
based on who you are and what you want
then you are more likely to be damaged
because your decision making is cute if
you don't want to be having sex with men
but you you're using sex as a way to
validate your beauty to validate that
you are somebody that is desirable then
that is damage and a lot of women in
that situation some girls just I think
they just enjoy sex literally some girls
got crazy set straps I'm done some of
them but why can't you do that with one
person that knows exactly in and out
what you like because the problem is
finding and the person that's compatible
you're lucky that you found somebody
that's so young and you work there as a
woman I'm gonna agree with a level and
say like what what is this is what I
don't get about this space what is the
obsession with like judging other
people's sexual partners and like what
they do I don't understand how grown man
will sit down and be like because we
have children with this many people you
know this right let me tell let me ask
you a question because we have children
to raise and if I have five girls I do
not want somebody who is sexually
liberated to teach my young female
children to grow up in a world
that they feel like they can just go
around and sleep around but you can't
search
and ain't gonna have no repercussions
now no one's saying that you can't go
out and sleep with whoever you want to
no one's saying that but what we're
saying is that comes with repercussions
and consequences and the consequences
are if you're looking for a husband
you're going to be deemed less valuable
but I think so to some guys what were
you gonna say so forget what I was going
to say I just want to respond to what he
says I think um when you um when the
problem is that now social media are the
women people that have been sexually
liberated or whatever you want to call
it
um they say you know just do what you
want to be do just be free and I think I
mean as a woman I can't judge other
women like dude your thing it doesn't
affect me right it's not like I'm gonna
marry you but I think um the one thing
that lacks in our society right now is
the fact that there is no education for
consequences of what actually happens if
you sleep with 20 50 because I know
girls personally and I don't know three
four five ten girls I know multiple
girls that at my age have body counts of
over a hundred over 100.
what's the consequences from that
because you can catch an STD sleeping
with one person and you can catch an STD
sleeping 100.
my question is is what is the concert
for example yeah I was going to say it's
mental you lose it why don't you start
comparing every man that you slept with
and no one is ever enough and I know
that for myself yeah because you may
find someone for example our
relationship someone might look at it
it's not perfect whatever but for me
it's perfect I can easily say that it's
classified I mean you both like fitness
models so I think you do a different but
but
next season like literally besides each
other yeah so the way I started and the
way that you started was literally
what I was saying is like there's always
going to be something right the fact
that he freaking drops his towel on the
floor when he comes out the bathtub that
piece off
[Laughter]
give her the whole bed the fact that you
you know you there's certain things
you're always going to not like about a
person there's always little you know
icks but nowadays woman's lists of icks
are ridiculous and then you look at your
partner that you're with at the moment
and I and I see that through some of my
friends and they'll say oh he's missing
this then yeah and then they'll see that
in someone they may be working with or
they meet in a club or whatever and all
of a sudden it's like oh he fulfills
that 20 or that 10 and all of a sudden
they're missing out and then they go
into that relationship and they find out
actually but then they went into that
one and it's that one's missing it they
mess up a good thing because they're
looking for the one thing that that guy
didn't have instead of just working with
what they got basically yeah
I would also I think I would argue that
a lot of the women that sleep around
aren't necessarily Unable to pair one I
think they because in my experience they
do want relationships have that deeper
connection with someone so but they
can't because
too many people so I don't I think it's
like um I don't think girls girls girls
want to be with like the best that they
can do basically and so I'm definitely
punching
and and so the the thing is like the
more men that a woman slept with the
less likely he is the best that she can
do but but like look at I mean
there's times where like
and and then it's like she can't do as
well because you know he'll find out
about three guys she slept with
I feel like I have my wife in that one
I'm good it's true but that that's what
I think it is I think that the standards
get higher and I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing but obviously
when this awkward situation now where
like you know that that competition is
getting a bit unreachable for most dudes
um but yeah but I I do think like this
conversation is weird because it's both
like spiritual and like reality so in
reality the fact is we have there's
objective levels right like you know
there are objective standards between
what you want a man is willing to invest
in for a long-term relationship on the
other side you should be able to kind of
express yourself really and not not be
judged in that way because I don't think
every time someone sleeps around us
necessarily because they're there so you
need to kind of have some traditional
conservative opinion on oh she's this or
that I know a lot of women who can have
casual relationships and they know the
boundaries and I know a lot of people
who tell themselves they can have cash
relationships without actually looking
for something deeper and as women who
you are doing that but they actually
damaged there's women who are kind of
virgins but they're deeply traumatized
you know it's not the world isn't that
simple I think that Nuance needs to be
there of like I agree
you're right bro but how do we create a
filter to find out who's who you guys
don't know let me tell you how because
the world has done it for time every
with anywhere else in our lives other
than relationships everybody follows the
same rules credit score as soon as you
go to get a loan what's the first thing
they do they look at your history when
you got to get a job what's the first
thing you look at your history when you
get arrested and you make a crime what's
the first thing they look at so how do
you find their history handles
yeah yeah now it is it's on your social
media it's everywhere
that's the problem like I think that one
of the best interests I think one of the
best Industries like I think I think one
of the ways I think one of the best
Industries going forward is going to be
um a racing women's sexual Past online I
think that's going to be like you want
to be rich the thirst traps you were
like
um there's traps you're posting when
you're 18 it's it it's a shame for you
in a way because you're paid to do it
but it's like I could see how that would
no like there's definitely times where
like I definitely don't do anything
extreme now it's more like well actually
I'm like quite invested in someone at
the minute so I'm not talking to any
guys but
um
it is some things I have posted and I
know they're gonna come back to like
bite me in the ass one day and I do
really regret that so yeah I can see
what you're saying yeah and I think
people would pay thousands of dollars to
get some of that [ __ ] like you twerking
I've literally been sent like 2K from
one guy just for conversing and like
talking and like talking I was like I'll
have an insecure about my nose he was
like oh let me send you the money for it
and I didn't send any news or like yeah
crazy you know
um okay you go and then go ahead can I
just say this may sound a little bit
barbaric but I say this to all my
friends and they hate me for it he's
probably gonna tell me off later but
like I feel like
um there is certain like some people are
just better than others like you can
just some people will just you know
whether that's looks or the decisions
they make and it doesn't mean that every
girl that has slept with you know loads
and loads of guys is traumatized or hurt
or you know she's trying to to forget
something sometimes it just means that
she makes really bad decisions and I
mean still a holder exactly that doesn't
mean that she makes you make bad
decisions and that's just as a whole
that makes bad decisions because there's
many good decisions
this is so stressful because what these
what these like I'm sorry baby you know
I love your respect for Alex
it does work tell us would you describe
it yeah you gotta use a word to describe
one okay I'll just say she gets around I
don't know I've I've become she does a
tank I kind of reach this point of like
avoiding being unnecessarily
disrespectful so so for me and I think
this happens a lot in the space of like
people get so obsessed with this
conservative Viewpoint of having to
judge people and I think people get a
kick out of being like huge like with
three people four years ago so you are
bam or if you don't do this then you
aren't good enough for these standards
XYZ and I get that I'm that is not wrong
at all but I think
eventually and I had a bad hinge there I
learned this like yesterday
yeah well I went off on about like we
were talking and then she was obviously
a feminist and then we had that feminist
conversation and she just first date I
do I filter
that's smart okay if you if you have any
of those like you know those like all
men are stupid or my brother's dumb
because he wants to be in finance he's
supporting the patriarchy I was like all
right so your family so what would you
you say people thought you were like an
[ __ ] that kind of conversation yeah
um and I can afford to do that but
essentially I got kind of reverse
traumatized because you basically didn't
say anything and she was very
intelligent one to the top uni in London
and I kind of realized that traumatized
me I was like well she she really didn't
talk she didn't like normally they you
know the delusions come out and it's
like this that and I kind of realized
that was just unnecessarily mean I guess
like you know even if she didn't meet
any standards or she had any silly ideas
about being you know sexually liberated
or having people she slept with you
didn't I didn't really need to do that
like you know I could have seen the best
in her and assumed she was a decent
person who wants a meaningful
relationship with I think 99 of people
are but instead I went with the red pool
stuff and you know it you know so so
that's why I'm on this like do we have
to call each other
learn better language there's a
difference she going up to a random girl
you don't know and calling her a hoe and
describing
yeah obviously in person obviously in
person but sometimes even in a group
dynamic like I think I think we all know
what that is without having to be like
because we all know who is a derogative
it's not respectful terms that's that's
why you wouldn't say to someone in
person but I'm just saying like we never
have this conversation about like simps
like thank you
yeah and and so it's like if I I don't
think it's derogatory to call a man a
Sim no it's not and I would do it I
don't think I think it is I think it is
terrible that's you like that's you this
like burning like putting your finger in
the sky but it's like if you call a man
a simp he might stop simping
no I think sometimes like that's how a
lot of guys in the red pill space get
started they called it but yeah most
guys I think I think most guys have been
taken advantage of by a girl they were
simping for at some time absolutely I
can name my hundreds yeah I know I know
I know I'm know I know a list of people
that are simping as hard as they
possibly can oh yeah I know a lot of my
sisters
same thing with girls like if you start
getting called a hoe you might do it
less but not really do what you want
more of a like a it has a more of a
permanent kind of stamp like no no I
would say [ __ ] or something
yeah
if you call someone
you can't be like no you've changed
I don't mean to call you out but then
you come in and the first thing you said
like like that's a fun time fun time I
do I wouldn't allow um
my daughter's 18 and there's no way I
would be like Oh yay you're a ho because
it's fun you might not hear it but she's
probably doing no she's about having sex
she's having no no not that and I didn't
mean that I mean just like
some I don't remember though you know
she's not but it's like I wouldn't as a
mother to a girl be like oh this is a
fun time if this if it was a fun term I
would be okay with using it but it's not
a fun damn no yeah
it's the same thing I'm just a fan of
being honest and like Simpsons hoes are
hoes I'm not going to change the
language
what I've noticed about women is that
the second they want to diss another
woman so in your own world forget men
for a second when another woman wants to
degrade another woman what's the first
thing they call her a flag you're a hoe
you're a slag you're this you're at that
because they know within their own group
that is
you're not going to get offended like if
someone calls me a [ __ ] or ignorant or
something yeah cool but if someone calls
me a slug or something I'll be like get
your facts straight I do yeah
if you slept with more than one person
someone can say if you're like sorry
you're saying I do think that it does
just depend on the person like I have
friends that like they're 19 their body
count is like over 100 yeah 100 yeah and
they're proud hoes like they literally
call themselves how they call themselves
a slag they call themselves
like what she was saying though I do
think some of my friends are like they
have trauma and they are damaged in a
way where
like they don't under that's the only
way they can seek validation is from
having sex with men it's very unhealthy
but it's very exciting if they were if
they were like taught from a young I'm
not saying young young but like for if
they were maybe given the facts about
things like we spoke about like
parabonding or the the likelihood of
divorce and the likelihood of not
finding someone or not do not think that
they might actually okay fair enough I
[ __ ] up in the past but you know what
I mean
statistically how many people are
growing up in one parent families where
they're not taught that Dynamic of two
parent households so they're not taught
how to I'm just saying I'm just talking
generalization I'm not telling you
personally
um if like it takes that Dynamic so
you're an anomaly
I just don't buy it like when the girls
are like oh I didn't know I had no idea
like if you didn't know then your first
reaction when a girl pisses you off
wouldn't be a call or a [ __ ] like I
think innately we we know I don't know
if I think it comes from what your
parents didn't know your parents might
not teach you these kind of it comes
from a lot of things I think the women
are blurring the line of the word hoes
or the women are in between being a hoe
and being married and that space in
between there is a dangerous space for
women to be because the ho ho is like
real hoes like for real that know they
come in and smashing everybody in the
room they don't give a [ __ ] like you
said they're proud hoes and they'll let
you know that they're a hoe and they'll
make it clear that we hoes and we out
here twerking and then the girls who are
married like you at the other end of the
spectrum I have a different perspective
the women in the middle that are single
trying to get out of the whole phase
trying to get out of the whole section
that's why they blur the line of like oh
I'm not a hoe I'm just dating on this is
just my face this is my tattoo I think I
think it's a mating strategy though like
I think it's just like the top like
women fight for the top 20 percent of
men five percent of whatever it is ten
percent immense attention and I think
like there's a group of women that know
they can't get their attention any other
way it's like either they're too far
gone so there's no way they're gonna
wipe them so you know what [ __ ] I'll
just I'll just signal easy sex easy sex
easy sex and I'll get their attention
and that goes down that goes down to
insecurities that goes into self-esteem
I don't even think it's self-esteem I
think like the world will just let you
know real quick where you're at I think
I think it's like I like no I think it's
girls that are punching that's true you
know you might girls I mean how many
how I mean Brittany Renner right
yeah do you know what it is
she's so far gone that no no guy's gonna
watch her right now
that's what I'm saying but like she's so
far gone wait wait wait so yes yes I can
um so Brittany Renner um she's uh she's
no she's a publico
um so basically she's just been with a
lot of like athletes rappers
entertainers like that's she's like
known for sleeping with a lot of people
in the industry so much so she wrote a
book yeah and like she didn't use any
other names but people kind of put
together who they were and then she also
like posted videos about like how to
catch a baby off of an NBA player like
yeah okay no you know what is sad about
like public figures like this like no
hey do what you want to do Etc but I
remember literally being in secondary
school like 15 14 years old and like my
friends would get up her videos on
Instagram and they'd be like oh see so
like it is fine that my body can't exist
and it is fine I've had sex with this
many people like I don't care I don't
but sex is being so devalued in today's
society Society sorry but yeah like I
don't think it should be praised to be a
hoe I think yeah if you want to be
sexually free be sexually free you're
gonna find someone who doesn't care that
you're sexually free or they have a
sexually free past like just like we
were saying you accept people for their
flaws some people would but you're right
there's a symphony I do think I do think
public figures like that is quite a
negative impact on Modern that's that's
simple it's not going to be the guy you
want though to jump in because what
you're saying they're like
about the way that Brittany renner's put
out and no one really talks about what
comes after I think that kind of goes
back to what it was saying before where
the consequences of that behavior needs
to be discussed from those girls that
are doing that yeah
it's like it's fine I think you know
whatever your lifestyle fair enough but
I think just going around the real life
consequences of things is that I think
it's the real issue of like listen if
you want to do your you know your your
promiscuous phase or whatever fine but
let me just tell you what happens to
people who do that in the wrong way and
let's not like dance around that but I'm
not gonna be like oh you slept with too
many people you're not good enough for
this is the question
that is the consequences I just think
[ __ ] yeah I just think I think no one's
really shouting but okay but I just
think I just think shame
um like it changes your behavior the
same way like when I was at work and
those guys being like yeah like I would
not touch a girl over too they didn't
know like because I I carry weight well
because I'm tall and so I don't think
they knew how much anyways but
um it's like hearing that like brutal
honest truth made me change my behavior
and I just think it's the same thing to
an extent but in this case I don't think
it works like that because in your
circumstance you could lose weight but
if someone slept around they can't go
back in the past and not sleep around
the neck so so what you're doing is
basically passing judgment but you're
kidding yourself saying oh well
there's no Redemption what are you
talking about how is redeemed like I'm
sorry okay so let's just let's just be
here wait
um so let's let's just we all know a
girl that's that's kind of rebranded
herself yeah yeah okay 100 you meet them
at University they all start at
University there was a hose in their
ends and then they come to UNI and try
and be wifey and the girl that was wifey
and ends comes to UNI and goes mad truth
faster Asian Community because the girls
that were part of the Asian Community
like Indian girls they used to go mad in
uni you know why because they were
prisoners at home yeah yeah and this is
the reality everybody wants the
wishy-washy and blur the lines but I
think it's not it's not wishy-washy bro
I'm not saying I'm not saying there's no
such thing as a whole and I'm not saying
it's a good thing I'm just saying that I
think a lot of a lot of the way we talk
about it sounds like it's unnecessarily
negative and judgmental for people who
I'm I'm a big fan of shaming when you
can do something about it
with 20 people it's like well she can't
change it
yeah Alex Alex she could she could stop
sleeping with the whole football team
yeah maybe you could stop if I was
advising her I'd be like look
you might want to move
my channel
s this question would you rather have a
girl that slept with 20 or sometimes
I'll say 10 depends on the day but 10 20
dudes you don't know or three you do
know
most guys most guys and this is most
guys will pick the 10 or the 20 that
they don't know you know what if I don't
have to see them if I don't have to meet
them what like I don't know
okay okay yeah I'm gonna be dreaming
about those dudes
I'm just saying if I was advising this
girl I'd be like look you gotta stop one
you gotta stop doing what you're doing
yeah you might know how to move cities
gonna have to yeah and and so I'm not
saying like you can ever come back like
she's still a hoe deep down but that's
that's what I would tell you I
understand so you're talking about
continuously being on her yeah okay fine
always a hoe like do you think that
she'll ever be able to be a committed
relationship if she slept with someone
like 50 people okay okay I'm just saying
if she if she came to me and and was
asking me for advice yes I wouldn't
advise a guy to date her like if the
guys were but I'm just saying like read
it but I'm just saying she's looking for
a husband if she's saying you know I'm
really done and I'm really I I
personally think once a hoe always a hoe
papa will give no references
I won't be referring but if she said
what's the best way to come out on top
you're like okay
she has a nice hair
she's charismatic she's charismatic
she's popular
I hear what you're saying though like so
you're talking about like trying the
continuous Behavior yeah but I but I
also wouldn't say to like make it super
hard like because you're still a hoe
deep down so you can't like the
born-again Virgin going to church thing
like if a guy's actually taking you
serious why are you gonna make him it
that hard for him to sleep with you if
you know what you are actually I was
speaking with a friend recently
um and um she is 30 something and she's
in a relationship and she still hasn't
slept with her boyfriend that she's been
with for like three or four months he's
sleeping with somebody else
virgin no but that's the thing and I
know and I and I um and I said to her
but why are you making him wait when I
know you slept with guys after like a
week and she was like yeah but you know
I'm not doing that anymore
I want him to respect me and obviously
he doesn't know her sexual past so she's
dumb though he's dumb brother
no no no because the thing is if I was
to get out of my relationship for
example I know I wouldn't be able to
press them but yeah exactly
if you're gonna talk
but that's what I'm saying I wouldn't
like I wouldn't have been able to sleep
with someone for a very long time even
if I started dating I reckon I would
have that rule of at least I don't know
either you're an exception to the rules
but that's what I'm saying you don't
believe a girl so he might believe her
because she's been in a lot of long-term
relationships and then she might say
actually I have put it put it put it
this way from me and from my experience
as soon as you start talking to a new
girl she's never slept with no one for
the last six months all of them every
single every time you speak to a new guy
I haven't been with no one for the last
six months oh I haven't slept with no
one last night who are you talking to
Bro nowadays will tell you every guy
but I'm saying we're talking about
General you're talking about exceptions
to the rule the general consensus of
women will play PC
they're not going to tell you how it is
so okay you think they tell you exactly
in my experience because I'm meeting
these days will be like oh there's a cue
for me
all right wait okay
um what about you what do you think do
do women tell you
no 100 no maybe some some girls are
honest and proud our proud hoes but most
I've said eight percent they ain't gonna
tell you they'll be like six months old
I've slept with two guys three guys and
then multiply that by you know what I'm
saying I'm seeing someone that is such
an annoying thing to say I have a
question for the for the girls okay so
as women we all know we know we will
always know more than the men about
women's sexual history would you guys
agree with that 100 so so like when we
have friends like they'll tell us more
than their boyfriends know and they're
so so we know who gets wiped faster host
hoes or prudes
hoes my friend well actually yeah I've
got friends that are always in their
marriage and actually second and then
second question and do their men have
any idea so no okay no no what about no
I honestly do think you find like most
of these like single 40 year old women
that like are like sad that they're not
wiped up decide that they don't have
kids in that it's because they were hoes
like in their past and they regret it so
much and like that goes back to the
Brittany Renner thing I was saying like
it's really dangerous for young women
because they do end up regretting it you
think prudes get wafed up yeah you say
fruits um you said hoes you think hoes
get wafed up fast confidence okay what
about you you think hoes get wafed up
faster me yeah
um I think just something I don't well
out of my friends the ones that were
hoes when we were younger are married
the ones that weren't are married
because they've been very career driven
okay what do you think I think it's a
mixture I feel like I know certain
friends who are hoes hoes but their man
don't know so that's why they get
whiffed up but then I know certainly
improved to get no men at all so I feel
like it just depends how you present
yourself do the prudes present
themselves like hoes
um no but then I feel like
it just depends because I know majority
of my friends are approved I also feel
like they don't
like put themselves in a position to
date like for example let's say they
like to dress up wear makeup and just
look cute I feel like they actively just
withdraw from the game and they don't
put themselves out there like they just
don't have game like that's the best way
to explain it where the hoes like have a
it goes both ways but like that yeah it
goes a bit more game they know how to
make money yeah and I think because
they've been with more men they know the
right things to say they understand that
a little bit better than the people yeah
but then I know certain friends that are
just so ho-ish that because everybody
knows they don't get wife so it just
like it just literally depends on how
you present yourself really
I'm just curious what roughly the girls
I don't even know if you could do this
because I mean they might lie to YouTube
but like if you're the gas roughly what
body count gets waved to the quickest
[Music]
you guys may know roughly because you
know the behind the scenes so I'm just
curious if you no I think what um sorry
what was your name Bella no um Valentine
Valentina
um what you said was a very valid point
because the girls that may have slept
through a few bodies they will know how
to act to pretend that they're this you
know High Almighty and but there's
someone that's actually a prude
they'll just keep themselves to
themselves and not go out there whereas
someone that slept with 10 bodies 10 15
20 whatever they'll go up and and
they'll play the game oh I I I have a
number and I can validate okay okay go
ahead what do you think I think it's
something I'll ask you after sorry go
ahead I think it's seven plus seven but
seven to ten seven to about 10 12. the
reason is the fastest yeah I think so
but because and I can kind of tell I I
judge everyone just by like how they are
and I don't do any of this like oh this
was your past I can see I can see your
passing yard isn't it so yeah just just
look just talk to people you can see I'm
sorry I don't believe men though well
there are a lot of losers out here but I
definitely know that you're not getting
anything [ __ ] anyway we don't know [ __ ]
so seven seven plus because she's
probably he's a woman who probably had
two or three serious boyfriends in high
school and then they've probably had
about two to three kind of sexual kind
of Encounters in University and then
they figure out so the whole thing is
about being smart some girls sleep on a
little bit and then they figure it out
some people keep on sleeping but that
seven Mark is when like she's seen
enough she kind of gets it now you've
been to UNI you've had the high school
boyfriends you've had a couple dudes
that you need you you get how this works
you're gonna find a good guy when it
gets past like 12 clearly you haven't
figured this out so clearly you know it
just extends and I can see it like I
disagree because one of my friends yeah
she's my age she's 20. she's married and
I'm not joking her body count is 65.
that's not a whole liar come on no it's
not a normal person that's what I'm
saying like some people are like I feel
like women have the power of like again
like I feel like men because I don't
want to be rude but I feel like men have
fragile Egos and once a woman knows how
to work around it
like like I said how you present
yourself is crazy like men didn't make
up that say what he doesn't know doesn't
hurt him we didn't make that up
we didn't make that up what he doesn't
know doesn't hurt him we did not make
that but you know why that was made up
men say that I mean I don't
know a phrase came from well she don't
know wait yeah wait um so I don't
actually know where the phrase came from
I always hear men say that with like
cheating which I always say it um
it's in a situation where we know women
are adding numbers on that they just
erasing you know I mean erasing it
doesn't exist so yeah but at some point
knowing knowing is just like negative
benefit like it's not needed you're not
helping yourself
victory in the woods if you if you're
not there to hear it fold did you
actually did it actually fall I'm
curious do you think if he found out the
husband would um would they get divorced
no
um because of their religion as well oh
she's religious yeah Muslim as well
she's a cucumber and I feel like
probably you know I don't know I really
don't know but I feel like they would
not get stoned I think there'd be a lot
of family
it's not nice to say well I've also got
another question though what if yeah
this person has a body count of two and
they're with their mouth for a year and
then she [ __ ] his brother does that
make her a hoe or does that make her
yeah
but she has a body count of two yeah
like I don't I don't think it's like
black and white like I think there's
some things that you can do that are
just like mad I like the way
up her body counts
wait okay guys no side stop um if her
body counts too but she slept with two
guys in one night
is that better than a girl with seven
no that's what I'm saying same time is
Ohio really baked the spectrum of hoism
is so vast yeah we're gonna be here all
night
numbers it's based on intention exactly
we've been saying all this stuff
stop stop stop stop stop stop
thank you I usually talk over people and
I've been quiet thank you anyway I agree
with my name what with what my Nemesis
said I actually like it today I'm proud
of you because you cannot call a woman a
hoe when actually she is experiments so
she can know and make better decisions
because it's very dangerous I'm listen
I'm not even talking to you too because
I think that's an exception to the rule
in the day in today's age but I think
it's very irresponsible for you to
expect a woman to go into a relationship
with you and think and know what it is
that you bring to the table as a man
where she doesn't know what a man can
bring to the table he can't bring to the
table women need to go through
heartbreak women need to experience men
to know and be better trust me trust me
listen listen do you know what
especially in today's age it is
necessary because we we are actually
programmed to make bad decisions because
the world around us is actually not that
great I think so we need to learn
what why why do you need more trauma to
bring into a relationship it's not about
trauma it's about experience come on
everybody
capping every time you break up with
someone or you get broken up with
there's trauma there's heart problems
it's baggage maybe it's lessons maybe
even a kid and you could you could you
could phrase it like that but most men
would disagree because we all complain
to the next guy but you know let me tell
you something about men and this is the
thing I think is becoming the problem
men were used to women succumbing to
their needs and their wants because they
needed a man to survive no no no I'm not
I'm just telling you wait a second right
which means that now that a woman can
work anyone can provide for herself many
to kind of relax on their standards
because you will not get a woman that is
going to be a virgin in this day and age
and be a woman that is actually
naturally and I mean socially accept to
go to the East and I'll just fly to the
East and find out yeah and how are you
going to feel good going to these things
like that you never there's one on the
panel but she was 15 when she met her
and she yeah
and that's even better because you were
in for two years because you were yeah
men men are not picky they're not picky
at all you are being picky if you're
asking for a virgin you know but most
men don't expect okay okay how many men
here expect to get a virgin
so so most men don't expect a virgin
they just don't want a girl that's had
her ass on her Instagram that has only
fans and that slept with more than like
15 dudes guys I I've you know I've
interviewed a lot of guys it seems to be
ton but then I asked them a second
question and then it's like yeah we have
chemistry maybe 50.
that's not a crazy standard I'm so true
I do think so like a lot of guys
initially chat to me because they expect
me to be like some crazy [ __ ] hoe
who's just gonna like jump on their dick
first chance I get but yeah like so
they'll only like me in a sexual sense
but then once I do tell them I'm a
virgin and like if they believe me
um because of how I present myself
um they do start to think of me
different and they do start to look at
me and way where it's like yeah I could
wife her like yeah like I could look
past the house on Instagram like yeah
because they do value like but yeah
would you delete all those pictures or
would you leave them up no no I'd have
to have someone that was like because I
like expressing myself in that way I
like showing off my body I like that but
yeah but she's still a virgin she's
spirit so it's not good no no no out of
curiosity I just wanted to know if she's
gonna leave that for respect you know I
mean I think most men would prefer
neither like I don't think they'd care
that much I'm not saying like like but
she gets that she's not she's a beauty
though what I'm saying is I think
sometimes we need to understand that
there's a difference between what we
want and what we need that's it like
what you need is not I don't think men
need a dude or sorry I don't think I
need a girl that slept with 20 no but
what I'm saying is a man doesn't also
need somebody that I slept with less
than 10 a man needs a woman that is
going to be there for him that's going
to support himself you go you go through
the substance of how much a woman can
add to your life even listen this is the
thing I I I've gone gotten to a stage in
my life where I don't want to judge
people and I'm very forgiving if you
genuinely have genuine kind intentions
toward me I don't care about anything if
I can trust you can prove to me that you
can trust that can trust you now and
forever we have that Bond then great I
don't care so what matters to men though
is they want they want to look like
respect is really important to guys and
so if a guy brings in a girl and he
doesn't know that she slept with like
three people in that room or they go to
a new town and she's been with this guy
and that guy like life is long if you
slept with 20 30 people like you're kind
of bound to run into them at some point
so it's like what about girls bumping
into uh the girls that the guys used to
[ __ ]
and I think most girls don't care they
don't but if they if wait if they do if
they do I they have every right to do
that I think that's fine okay boys start
staying virgins in it
I think that um stay virgins then
because we have no control of that yeah
I think pure I think we need to identify
that a lot of the time when we have
these conversations we are talking about
high value men and when we're talking
about you know someone that has I think
it's quite clear at this day and age
that a lot of people know that women are
born with value and men have to gain
their value as they work and create
their value I personally think that
women don't even know how to identify
like that word high value exactly right
now has been like
for like on a general idea is somebody
who can pay their bills keep a roof over
their head feed themselves the basic the
basic Provisions
sorry sorry the high value man is what
say that again so a high value like for
me yeah what puts you in the first like
bracket of being high value is being
able to provide yourself before yourself
fully so if you feed yourself clothe
yourself
um home yourself you know have like
spare stuff going on that you can do
you've reached a point of high value
because there is a lot of people
let me finish let me finish no listen
let me finish let me finish just like
this just like there's a whole Spectrum
there's also a high value Spectrum do
you understand so the bottom the bottom
end of high volume is being able to
provide because there is a lot of men in
this world that cannot do that yes now
what happens those are the ones that we
say they're trash what happens is women
are looking at the top tier of the high
values which is which is the basketball
players the football players no these
guys and these guys hold on let me
finish and these guys are not the men
the husbands that you all claim you want
because they're the most ones that are
least monogamous they have the most
options and everybody's going for them
but the stuff that you're actually
asking for the dudes just below them and
slightly below actually a more
overqualified to actually provide that
but because you're so looking up in the
stars and gazed by the lights you're
actually missing the real dudes that
you're supposed to grow with as a
journey like these two have well I I say
the average and I got cheated on so it
made no difference it probably wasn't
average if you had the option to cheat
he was probably above average but but
there's like five pillars of high value
man it's not just like taking care of
your bills and they they talk about how
entertainers aren't in the high value
Man category automatically thank you
they're not they're not why do people
act like these
no it's like um basketball players
um they they're like have a 92 chance of
getting divorced within like five years
after leaving the league and um football
players it's like a 60 or 70 and uh I
think it's higher than the I think it's
78 chance of getting divorced but Kevin
Samuels there's like five pillars of a
high value man yeah no I watched Kevin
and that's what I was saying like this
spectrum right and that's what I'm
saying like the base the basic level
which most majority women who are also
on that same level they miss that what
do you mean the same level though
because can I just finish my point when
I because I started talking about the
high value men right about the fact that
we're talking about so let's say high
volume if I'm talking about a high value
man I'm talking about he's probably
making about
18 in UK 80 plus K he's got his own
apartment yeah I I personally would
speak like that right so essentially why
would this man work for 20 years or
whatever to establish himself and then
he why would he want to be with a girl
that um has slept with 20 30 guys don't
get me wrong I'm not saying that every
single guy that's over 30 wants a 21
year old because some people do actually
want someone to grow old with and have a
nice conversation with it's not just
about sex and fertility but at the end
of the day there is they've got the
Spectrum to choose if we're just talking
about guys like yourself
regular guys yeah
that you know making all right money but
really and truly can they really ask for
a virgin but when they get when they get
there no they have their own why when
they get to make it so because because
she's not that she's not one percent
Ain't nobody got the right to ask for no
virgin what are you doing
you're the same girl that'll say women
can ask for whatever they want but men
can't ask for when did I ever say that
they say that oh you insinuated often
often you know I say as a person
please stop stop guys okay
okay I don't even remember what we're
talking about now Federation what I was
saying match your level as in yeah yeah
no you're right I think actually a lot
of times like The Virgins aren't who
guys would think like I think if you
like a lot of virgins I know are really
awkward I don't even think they would
like I'm learning things or that
attracted like I don't know and also if
somebody's at 80 130 Grand a year are
they they're going to be of a certain
age right so they're not gonna meet
somebody who's single that's in their
20s that's a virgin that's necessarily
at their level that they want to match
and grow with because nobody now you
want to meet a woman who's also doing
her thing and not just our home waiting
for their man to come and no you guys
like that they want a girl that's
waiting for them to come back
because if the girls just sat at home
waiting for the man to come and marry
they don't they don't really care yeah
yeah
isn't your girlfriend at home all the
time
someone I'm six days at home depends on
the guy yeah yeah some guys I I don't
think like the housewife stuff is nice I
haven't experienced too much of that
before but I definitely prefer like
someone who's also kind of doing their
own thing
yeah
like why do we so women have all these
like standards for men now you have to
be this and that I don't I don't think
it's bad for me to be like all right I
would hope you're educated and I hope
you're also doing something reasonably
respectable right it's not just me that
has to work in the top place you have to
be equally yoked that's me it's like
creative like because for me if I'm sat
at home doing nothing just waiting for
my man to come home like what I'm like
what am I doing like what am I doing
like what am I doing it's kind of weird
doing something else I mean cooking food
waiting for it yeah no I mean if it was
me there's always making another Bowl
I'm just just thinking if if it was if
you're married to a high value man
there's gonna be [ __ ] to do around the
house it's a full-time baby has he not
got a cleaner
what do I look like a cleaner no do you
know what's so crazy
wait wait wait if you're married to a
high value man why wouldn't you clean no
but why wouldn't we have a cleaner like
I have a cleaner like it's true they
always get penis though I personally
haven't I've got two children and I've
got my own creative things that I'm
doing so I'm not cleaning toilet I don't
know sometimes I'm retired some people
value privacy so it's like when you have
all these random people in your home you
guys you kind of lose an element of
privacy I mean yeah I mean you could
have a cleaner and we could have it
forever
there's always [ __ ] to do around the
house
I mean you can't I mean if you just talk
to I started messaging with like real
Homemakers oh my God they make all their
food from scratch like a lot of times
they Garden it themselves like like a
lot of them yeah running a home is not
easy
yeah we're meant to do that a lot of
times they watch the kids a lot of times
they'll homeschool them like yeah I
guess it depends on like
a lot of the women I meet in London that
are like I always feel like if if she
stays home a lot then she's gonna do all
this hard work but eventually she's
gonna be like oh I need some help and we
need to hire a maid uh we need we need
like a nanny to help because that's what
they do and then she'll want to do other
things and then naturally when
infidelity comes into the picture or
your your wife has like six hours a day
like so I can more easily trust someone
who also has a career because the women
who are kind of you know cheating in
their marriages or women who have spare
time
like man that's how I think but I don't
know it's so crazy that is that people
don't like the mean
you know like because when you when you
ask you said when you describe the high
value man the first thing you went to
was Finance do you not know that a man's
Financial Peak the point at where he
makes the most money in his life is 51
and that's what I was saying so if
you're not 20 five if you're not between
20 and if you're not between 18 and 30
and we'll be happy dating a 51 year old
get this fairy tale out of your head
hold on hold on let me finish let me
finish and just to go on what you're
about to say get better at picking a
dude who is going to become a high value
because you don't know how to pick you
don't know how to pick
can I say something
please please please talk in your mouth
I was just saying that like perspectives
you were saying the other week that it
was okay to be a Simon and be okay in
that position yeah isn't she married or
in a
relationships yeah but I'm not trying to
wipe it but then doesn't that devalue
you as a man no I mean
so so
I mean that would be nice but no I mean
women don't give a [ __ ]
do you think how many times is Drake
stolen people's girls it's our women oh
no I'm not sleeping with Drake well
that's kind of danger you're trading on
that little line of old girls and hoes
the same way the old men are trash
that's not really the case and I
actually when you're saying when did I
say when you when did I say matter trash
no I'm not saying that you said I'm just
saying this comparatively the same thing
where he's just coming out of your mouth
the same way that I could say oh man a
trash so you shouldn't really say it
like that's generalized what's when you
keep talking about girls don't care
girls do care and not every single girl
I'm saying by and large girls do not
care if men but they do what you're
seeing what don't what you're seeing and
what what the world is actually actually
showing you and what a lot of men
actually suffer with is the fact that
they are dealing with hoes and they
think every woman is a hoe and not every
woman is a hoe actually at the
percentage of a lot of women that are
host maybe I should quite small because
a lot of women have very high standards
so they're not even wanting anything I'm
not saying all women are hoes I've never
said that wait wait I I it's not wait
wait I'm not saying all women are hoes
I've never said that I've net you can't
catch me on a podcast saying all women
are hot but but I'm saying is that by
and large women don't care and the
reason the reason if they did so many
women that come on the show it wouldn't
be such a large percentage that have
picked men that cheat on them
and like women like women like men that
other women want to bang and there's
hundred percent
and there's and there's
I'll give you I'll give you an example
pickup artist teach men to wear rings so
they can get more girls because women
see that as a sign of pre-selection oh
if he married her he'd marry me and
women and and throughout history men
that could get multiple women it was a
sign that they could take care of those
women
so it's like so I'm not saying every
single woman you know some some women
have dads to like you know tell them
don't go there whatever whatever but but
I'm saying by and large women don't care
that's why they have it by and large by
and large even me like if a guy said oh
I slept with a married chick like am I
gonna care like it wasn't me
the girls do not like men that do not
attract girls fat guys guys aren't you
falling for that trap where you're
generalizing
in a way that doesn't serve you so
clearly clearly clearly you want the
woman that does actually care whether a
dude cheats on her yeah and that's what
I'm saying you know so clearly that's
what you'd be looking for right so
clearly clearly that makes everyone's
life easier right so if you're saying oh
most women don't like this most women
like
um Men Who cheat on them and Etc then
surely we don't want the ones that no I
said I said most women don't care if you
slept with a married guy but I think I
think even if I made the point of
handles being the side dude and because
it is the last one he had said and so it
was kind of like in my mind I was like
he's not like marrying up in what he's
saying in that moment so what she was
saying is that like as a woman if I met
handles and he was like yeah I used to
date a married woman would I care if I
want him and I feel that he adds value
to my life I wouldn't
yeah and I'm saying like by a large
woman don't care maybe we should
I'm not saying it's like the right thing
but like if I'm being honest with you if
you think he's handsome he's got a good
job he has all the things you look for
but he dated a married woman at one
point
um
you made a married woman step outside
the top woman I meet like the the a plus
woman
again intelligence is my biggest thing
they they'll she 'll she'll cut you out
if you like talk the wrong way she'll be
like this guy's a [ __ ] boy and I'm like
I did barely said because you're stuck
it's Alex but I just think it's because
you're not that guy to her no no and
that's that's fine but I'm saying wait
no I said to her I didn't say to anyone
but I'm saying like a lot of times like
when girls cut you out for stupid
reasons it's just because they don't
like you because the same girl that's
like because we again most girls talk
like we talked to these girls behind the
scenes you see how they move and they'll
be like oh I won't accept that that and
that and they won't from the guy they
don't like but if they like a guy yeah
some dudes get an application at the
front door and some dudes get let in the
back entrance yeah again they pay
nothing it's just like the clubs if some
dudes gotta line up and go through the
process and some dudes just get the gate
open one time I think I think you're
still you're still like targeting your
the way you think about this for the
woman you don't want in it I I think
it's not that girl was married to the
next guy and she went back to the guy
who she used to date at Uni she's off
the market French royalty do you want to
smile like she she I didn't say anything
like she could she could already kind of
tell that like I wasn't ready at the
time bro so I would say probably no I
don't really agree with what you're
saying you're talking about women on the
street isn't it no I'm talking about
women in general bro in just in just a
generalized situation like you have to
come to a level of agreement with
yourself as a dude where you go like you
know what I'm just gonna work on me
because there is nothing out here in
this world that can guarantee me or give
me any security about where a woman's
been unless I bump in back into her
while I'm in my teens young like these
guys right so once I've reached a
certain age you just kind of have to
accept regardless of whoever I pick
they're going to have a past regardless
now me as a what they like to call high
value man what I like to call the
difference is
I get to choose now I can choose and be
like do I accept your past
or do I judge you by your past based on
your current actions because every woman
and just like every man can be taught we
can all learn things we can all change
our habits and practice different ways
of applying ourselves do you see me
that's why you see do that will be a
gangster on a road and come home
religious it's the same thing with women
they can be in that stage until they
really take steps to get themselves out
of that stage and as soon as they're out
of that stage it's like an Unwritten
kind of broadcast that goes out where
it's like oh she's wiped up man I ain't
even gonna hold that no more even though
you might have hollered at her like a
whole back in the day but you can see
from your side man like you were saying
perspective oh she's taking her [ __ ]
serious good luck to you wish you the
best shout me when you're out of it like
that's the reality of it I'm just saying
I feel like people
people once you kind of hear this
rhetoric all the time where you
generalize based on the common you know
the average more than women which which
you probably don't want to have a
long-term relationship with I feel like
you start to see that all the time and I
think there's there's a lot more women
out here who are intelligent and who do
value their Chastity in in a way that's
sufficient for you know whatever
standards you may have but they're not
hot but I think no that they they just
have to notice right that's the thing I
think most men don't have that high of
Standards
I think this is like kind of a crazy
argument because men really don't ask
for much
I don't even know a single guy that's
saying oh oh like maybe one out of the
months I've done the show that said five
bodies is too many maybe one like most
guys they say they want they wait they
say 10 they say 10 but they mean 15 to
20 because like when I press them a
little bit if I say oh 20 but really hot
with good chemistry they're like ah I
let it go
you've got to be wary of of generalizing
people or women based on the women you
don't want because I I found them in my
in my life that
the more I see this in people and I've
realized in a lot of cases they won't
actually like that because because I was
thinking about you know all this kind of
rhetoric I judge them very quickly and
later realized oh [ __ ]
but it's a pointless point is I'm not
debating anyone I just I think the point
is like even if you get married it's
still 50 50 so you could say half aren't
somewhere
half are gonna leave here
but I'm not disagreeing with anyone else
like what what it sounds like to me like
I'm trying to decipher what you're
saying is that you should just give hoes
a chance that's like that's how it's
coming across no no I think I think we
should be with bro like we there's no
ugly hoes
I've heard guys say like the fours and
the threes because because they're just
like so happy to be there yeah they're
crazy for the attention
you don't even have to take her out to
dinner
as well you don't you just tell them
the girls you're talking about are the
bin like what we call paper bags plastic
Bagels where you put the bag on their
head that's what you're talking about
they're not hoes what are they them
they're not hoes let me tell you why
they hope they're not hoes yeah because
they don't have the ability to sell
themselves to the entire Market they're
like the men they're like the bottom of
the barrel
manually finish they're the bottom
they're the bottom of the barrel men who
take what they can just like how we know
men have sex with who they can and women
have sex with who they want you all know
a bunch of women then there's a lot of
girls they ain't host cause the whole
point is that most girls have sex
between security listen there's a lot of
girls that you know that ain't pretty
that ain't the prettiest of the bunch
but will sleep with anyone and take
whatever attention they can get this is
still a hoe just because she's not in
the top thing of beauty it doesn't mean
she's not right
so generally like making a general okay
so we can [ __ ] ugly and you've had lots
of dick in your vagina
no no no you're proven my point is
saying that the amount of people that
you sleep with makes you a hoe because I
only just talked about sleeping with
well past that but you proved my point
no you said an ugly God that's these a
lot of people can't be at home
we're going to move on from this okay
I'm gonna Read Super Chat so um guys
like the video um there's over 2 000
people watching I think there should be
2 000 likes on this video
um that's a big goal I don't I think
we've only gotten to 2009 a couple times
so make sure you guys are liking the
video I am going to read some super
chats I'm sorry if they're mean I'm not
yeah it's just me um okay all right
Elite gamer 876 Any self-respecting Man
Who Would wife up a girl who had a
history of long-term relationships any
girl who says I needed to heal or find
myself husband ran through you're going
to film miserably in a marriage
pan-african
um B mgtow patriarch women don't need to
go through heartbreak Bachelor for like
every girlfriend had the opportunity of
being one Western women are generally
the Destroyers of Legacy B mgtel men of
value blackest Panther you cannot be a
high value man if you have nothing to
out delegate to your woman you should
not you should be on your mission and
she should be helping you build a legacy
you are not your high value you are not
a high value man if your woman is Idle
doing her thing a man Dania
um denalva you should stop advocating
for people choosing to have bad
relationship experiences people people
normally learn learn what not to do from
other people's experiences that's toxic
advice give it up already just stop
um samay Tegan denalva you all don't
need six foot men but still want them
the UK Economist many of the problems in
the west such as broken families and
dysfunctional communities could be
solved if women waited until marriage
Traditional Values would be restored
um I mean I think that's ideal but
there's always going to be that
if you don't need experiences if you
don't need to experience stuff to know
it's bad experiences leave you with a
scar and Trauma learn from other
people's experiences duh truth don't
listen to the dude in the Hat men judge
her past have men judge her past and
have standards and build yourself up why
not to be harsh but divorce rates men
deleting themselves at a high rate child
support and custody battles and losing
half your resources all real not
manifested fairy tales amendania people
have sex no matter which of what
justification people have sex no matter
the justifications made not everyone
goes on to ride the carousel because
it's easy to do so it applies to those
to go down the road hence terms like hoe
skeet public property just saying Mo
blizz Pearl please let them know a real
man will always know if you've been
around a simple never know it takes
activating a certain part of your ego to
be able to sleep around a real man will
decode that fast black is Panther the
ladies on the couch have prude friends I
disagree if they're friends with you
then they are also 304s if you are
friends with a woman that depends if you
are friends with them a woman that
defends 304 Behavior then you're also a
304 thank you Elite gamer black is
Panther if you are if you meet a man who
dished out delicious knuckle sandwiches
to his exes on a regular basis should
that matter on whether you stay with him
his past doesn't matter he said he
wouldn't do it again Kamal Pearl you
need a black dress so help me God
married lady is an insanest human to
ever show up on the channel get her back
and again the other woman need to see
the other way come to the light ladies
blackest Panther why do women defend
being 304 so much but expect men not to
assume that they've also been a 304. if
your friends are 304s and by default you
are also 304 unless you are a 304 stop
defending 304 as Alistair Horton here's
a question would you rather someone
protects your ego and not point out a
problem letting it linger like a bad
fart or have them talk straight or have
it have them tell it straight to your
ego straight let your ego take the
damage and improve on it to prevent it
again black as Panther over indulgence
in anything that's easy to do is
shameful if you eat too much you're a
whale if you sleep around too much
you're a 304 if you do nothing too much
your lazy shame is important Kamara
Kamar he sounds simpish Trucking with
Tony Alex is a simp if she's a 304 it is
what it is kcf's back disrespectful
equals unflattering remark towards women
unflattering remark towards men it's not
disrespectful black is Panther sleeping
with multiple people is not what makes
you a 304 what makes you three or four
is why you sleep with them and how
quickly you move on from it C Dumbledore
sorry ladies but if you get paid to do
potty tricks in Dubai you're you're both
and you're never erasing that from your
past Almighty time married chick with
Spitting Fire Dennis McKinney noticed
the married brain thought versus the
single women KCF another word for 304
don't forget slag
um Henry Lucy tantric practitioner smoke
pipe on the side work is not is not just
escorting sugar baby sugar babies
Instagram models are all essentially
professionals
um Shell's shame is needed to hold
Society to a certain standard if you
want to bring back if you don't want to
bring back shame you're afraid of
accountability I'm Ryan thundered of God
one to four is unattractive 5.4 or 4.5
is barely smashed five is okay 5.5 is
cuteish six is cute 6.5 is attractive
seven is hot 7.5 very hot 8 is smoking
hot 8.5 or greater greater is supermodel
territory
um see Dumbledore
um
blonde could model the Chanel or the
channel what is channel Chanel oh Chanel
and it says c h u n n e l probably a
spelling mistake
um I don't know what that means okay
blonde could model the Chanel with that
Gap Dennis McKinney girl in the back
sorry if a girl on the background
asking the guys what they rate girl in
the back ask the guys what they rate you
I'm C Dumbledore if you have a poop
scoop Raptor claws anti aircraft
eyelashes and a meters of fake hair
you're not an 8.5
um Alistar Hort and most modern women's
egos are fragile as silent and silence
and it's usually to manipulate people
especially the emotional ones
um Eric Powell I love Pearl Dennis
McKinney's please start with the woman
listening to learn please listen with
your ears as a brain then put your heart
in it understanding of men will help
um you turn out better okay
um so back to the topic actually a
question for a man um not you you were
married
have you guys had a whole phase and how
long did it last
oh [ __ ] I thought you were 15. oh okay
maybe you did too he's a good looking
man I actually want to know bro I've
known this guy for like 10 years
we started we were meeting yeah all
right cool so her face for me it wasn't
that long it's like
for when I was I think like 14 got out
of another relationship started dipping
around and then I very quickly noticed
that I kind of had it easy with girls
so then I was just like all right cool I
don't need to be chasing like everyone
else likes doing and it was kind of like
a stereotype that was put on top of me
that I was gonna get someone pregnant
when I was young
so then I did the opposite and kind of
flipped it and I was just like you know
what I got options let me take my time
yeah pick who I want
and then move from there at least that
way I know that whoever's with me is not
with me for the success I'm gonna have
obviously this is me at 15. I don't want
to I knew that I was gonna end up being
in a good place in the future but I knew
that who I wanted by my side would be
someone that I knew was there for me and
not for the resources I can provide
exactly and that's a good choice that's
what you need people with the right
intentions for you masculine thinking
hey for me how long was your whole face
it wasn't long it was like a year a year
a year and what what stood out about
your wife that made you pick her you
know what there was a few things some
things that I was cute keep on the Reps
but it was very clear to see from the
get-go that she was gonna be there for a
long time and especially with the stuff
that I do outside of that professional
life she's so something that he doesn't
I'm so sorry my love that I'm
interrupting you but something that he
doesn't want to say in front of people
just not to
um he's a stripper no no it's just not
too um not to embarrass my family
um just out of respect which I
appreciate is but I don't mind saying it
is because
um we had a problem with race so my
family didn't accept him being black and
I chose him over my family and we moved
out so I think from a very young age we
were like 16. he knew that okay [ __ ]
like she's she's like he was so close
with his family like his mum his aunties
his grandparents and I can't imagine
someone standing he broke up with me
like three times I was like well nice I
was showing up outside this house I was
like don't look me in the ass tell me
you don't love me and then I'll leave
and he couldn't do it she proved it and
I think and I think that was the biggest
thing I'm shaking I'm shaking guys
we didn't want to go to the you you go
about answer your question no my mind is
uh mine started when I think I lost my
Virginia when I was 14 early when I just
turned 14. and I would say it went on
four until I was about
damn it's like seven years to tell us
about 21 but I went home in the whole
seven years I was like
you might be obviously attracted a lot
of girls and because I was popular in my
area and I chilled with a lot of people
and that was popular and was obviously
just going parties and just the man on
the party whatever
there will be a couple months in where I
won't even do nothing with a girl and
it'll be like maybe five months where
I'm just doing I'm just going crazy and
then yeah like when I hit about 21 22
kind of started to chill down and then
my mind kind of got a bit stronger I was
like I mean you need to do that you kind
of because he got used to it it's like
you don't really need to do that and
then you just kind of want to look for
someone
if you know what I mean yeah literally
so about seven years how bills seven
years
me yeah
um I don't know I don't even really like
I don't even really like to call what
men do a whole phase I don't really
think it's a hole I mean okay okay but
we could say they're Wild Oats yeah
can we just deal with the reality yeah
um I guess like I said probably like my
brother when I lost my virginity and
um you know you kind of know from seeing
how women interact with other men where
you kind of sit in the Spectrum and I
was like I didn't really have problems
sleeping with women you know I mean
coming up as as a young as a young guy
so I guess my my whole face is paused
when I was in relationships like I've
been in like three serious serious
relationships in my whole life and in
those in those periods I proactively try
to be you know everything that you would
want in that relationship but because
the people who I was with didn't make
that same commitment it just fell
through so like you know if I found
something like your wife where she's
pulling up outside your house I probably
would have been you know
more inclined to actually ride it out
and the person I actually had the the
longest and the deepest relationship
with was somebody who proactively
pursued me as well in a sense you see
what I'm saying whereas everybody else I
kind of you know made them my girlfriend
type stuff you know I mean because again
I make that choice
so
I don't know I don't think I don't think
I have I don't think I've left I'm
single now so I'm you know I guess I'm
back yeah
about you uh probably
about two or three years because so lost
my virginity in second year of uni which
is extremely late but I didn't I didn't
really like people in school so everyone
was dumb I didn't understand the reason
to get in relationships I thought they
were vacuous these guys running around
talking about who they whose hand they
held and then there was a there was a
town bike over there and it was just
dumb I was like I don't understand and I
still don't really understand much
relationships like what what why should
I like spend so much time talking and
building up some emotional relationship
um especially when you know if it ends
then you're distracted for like two
months until you reset or whatever so
uni
I've always been extremely picky though
so maybe a whole for me is different but
I've I have high standards of myself so
I like the idea that like some guys will
sleep with someone because she's up for
it it's disgusting to me it's like no no
so it's not me sleeping with you you're
also sleeping with me in that so you're
also in my space my energy and that's
kind of nasty if you just pick anyone
that's disgusting especially if women
who kind of are like that tend to be not
very picky in general I'm not
narcissistic enough to believe that like
I'm special but this this girl in the
club saw me and realized that I had an
aura and wanted to know is she's
probably gotten with the other three
Nigerian guys so so I've a follow-up
question do you guys feel like
um
men end up with the girl that met them
at the right time
like that was there when they were done
with their whole face and ready to
settle down or the or the woman that
they love the most the one that I think
the one that met them because I was a
muffins that's for nine years and he's
ended up with the one that kind of he
cheated and then he cheated and she then
was like the last cheat
if that makes sense so that he cheated
on each person with each person and then
he's ended up with the one that would
and maybe she accepted it it's weird
um so what what are you I was that so
guys what do you what do you think I
think it depends on the guy and where
their headspace is at because I mean I
know that I'm an anomaly so I can't
really talk for all guys but I know that
when we met I kind of already made that
conscious choice and I remember having
that conversation with my mum when I was
16 and being like yeah I think if I
started with this one that's gonna be it
but I can understand why most guys until
later in life won't really get to that
stage so I think is where they're at in
their headspace I don't think it's about
the time
um so you think it's it sounds like you
said more at the right time no no well
where they are yeah where they are so
the girl that's there at the right time
yeah okay all right would you guys agree
with that anyone disagree with that no I
don't disagree with that I agree with
that wherever like and the most men
won't even commit into a situation if
they ain't where they want to be in
their head yeah you know I mean if you
if I meet somebody because I can meet
somebody anywhere and at any time but
I've always got a master plan Pinky and
the Brain plan in my head that I've had
from since I was young that where I'm
gonna achieve in life so if somebody
comes in and shows attributes that
they're gonna add to that Journey
they're more like and more likely to
like keep that person around because
they're not taken away from where I'm
trying to go they're adding to it versus
if it's somebody who's got their own
life going on and they don't really want
to you know involve themselves in your
life so much it's kind of an easy choice
to me be like all right I'll hook up
with you but I don't see this going
Beyond where it is it feels more like
man is whichever one comes first if the
right one comes first they'll start for
the right one if the right one doesn't
come first they'll settle at the right
time but don't you think that's because
they can if it goes adapted or adaptable
to their lifestyle and they get on with
the program
then they can they can figure into what
they want from their life do you think
do you think that I'm just saying true
or untrue can the right girl make a guy
settle down when he's not ready untrue
yeah that's true that's true
respectfully I'm asking the man like
quite like that's true you should have
to be like seriously
like Kate Middleton like
serious okay so you guys all think
that's true absolutely I may ask a
question what is it that makes a man not
be wanting to settle if she's the right
one uh that makes us don't want to sell
they do if she's the right one why would
you pass on the right one the girl that
is actually has nothing wrong she likes
you like her everything
no I don't know maybe some men don't
want to give up that lifestyle that they
live in all to
the girl's attention or getting kills or
doing things with girls and they they
don't want to settle down I don't know
some guys just like the streets yeah so
that's what I'm saying some guys just
love them they're stuck in the streets
and they don't know how to get away so
so like uh I'm just saying like
obviously some
these situations we need to not also
take accountability because the right
woman will sometimes come across the
right the man and because he's not in
the right place in his mind because he
likes the streets too much because he
doesn't want to make sure that's the
other woman but that's not the point is
not that because if she picked him and
he has now a position of choice he's not
making the right choice
what are you talking about
who are you to say it's the wrong
decision maybe it's the right to sit
like sometimes it's the best thing that
ever happened to him sometimes it wasn't
okay and then so I said so this this was
what I said I said whichever comes first
so when you settle at the right time
that you feel like it's the right time
but you've missed out on the right one
it's likely to be the case where you're
gonna actually pick somebody that's
probably not gonna be the best for you
so I'll just say instead of you always
trying to think about the right time if
the right person comes along that's the
first priority that's it that's it you
shouldn't pass on the right side I think
that's a female point of that stuff
the right person because if we if we
find the right guy we'll drop everything
but like men just aren't built like us
but they all said if there's an
extremely exceptional woman they'll do
it yeah and so it's just you ain't that
girl
if this is the thing and that is also
one of the the issues that I have
because we like to point out problems
but then when the solution comes into
the table everybody rejects it how is it
that we can sit here and complain about
men or the girls this girls make my
decisions Men by make my decisions and
we're saying oh yeah if I'm not in the
right space now Let the Right One go and
then you're happy to say something like
that but we pick that like okay okay
women pick men that clearly aren't in
the space of their lives to settle down
like I'm sorry I'm 26. if I if I dated
26 year old he's probably not ready
women try to date their age and then
they're confused why he's not ready to
settle down this is why I want that like
yeah yeah I mean and there's like and
also I mean some some guys are right but
it's usually pretty obvious which ones
are and which ones are and if you ask
they'll usually tell you but we don't
listen okay so then let me ask you
another question and so since we always
keep talking about youth right
um I don't think youth in a woman means
it's the right time for for you to be
with her which means all these men that
high value in their 30 going for younger
women making mistakes you don't get to
pick it the men get to pick what they
want yeah that's what men find is
valuable is that me going into a shop
and like oh I want to buy this t-shirt
no you can't buy this t-shirt you go buy
this t-shirt okay because it's like if a
man if a man wants four kids why on
Earth would he pick a 30 year old okay
that makes no sense yeah I'm 35 and
there's no way I would date somebody who
wants to have multiple children I am not
ready to walk around with a big old
belly and have a baby on my baby yeah
and probably and you would be in
geriatric pregnancy I mean I think my
eggs are good but I mean you think but
you think yeah it'll be risky yeah
it's still a risk yeah and I'm not
willing why would a man I'm explaining
the simple fact that you cannot be
complaining about women saying that
women doing this in women doing that
when you're picking them at the wrong
time that's what I'm saying when all
those went to pick them exactly so then
so then while we're talking about age
I feel like you're getting too old
there's less trauma less baggage and
they look better okay the same way that
usually that women prefer the richest
the top one percent and actually a lot
of the time but the difference the
difference is what men want is
attainable what women want isn't it
what isn't crazy it's usually not crazy
under 30 under 30 roughly maybe you know
most guys will even be generous they'll
give you like 33 34 whatever
eggs are good I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry so again
but it's not crazy okay now I'll tell
you why it's also crazy because this is
again another problem we've met men why
are you picking just based on the fact
that woman is under 30.
update your skincare routine and your
past for younger all right that's what
I'm saying all I'm saying is
a man wants kids you're 30. 90 of your
eggs are gone that's okay
okay so so it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what you want or what you think
your eggs are gone
before you explain something let me cut
you off forever okay so I take back the
fact that I like you I don't like you
know more continue my tomorrow was um so
I always uh if you've seen rum diaries
with Johnny Depp
[Music]
I like that kind of lifestyle of like
being a well-traveled dude who's
experiencing so it depends on the guy
some guys are very conservative and they
want to settle down straight off the
university I always I always wanted to I
always wanted to experience the world
and to come back and have experiences of
value that would allow me to add an
engagement relationship in a certain way
which is why I'm a little bit more
tolerant than the conservative guys and
some of these standards so I'll take the
parents of the guy because I'm not
really driven by oh I'm gonna meet
someone we're going to connect so much
I'm going to drop everything
um it has to be a point where I've
decided in my mind that like all right
I've seen enough this is getting long
let me start like preparing to chill out
you know I do think that um like older
men and younger women do just go really
well together yep like because men
aren't ready to like put the streets
down so early and stuff like women do
tend to want to stop their High face a
lot earlier than men day like there's
this guy the guy that I'm talking to at
the minute like I literally just got
back from Portugal to see him
and like I can tell like I feel like he
would be ready to like kind of settle
down but if I met him when he was like
22 there is no way like I'm the right
like I feel like me and him have amazing
amazing chemistry like it's all perfect
like best time I've ever had with
someone but at 22 he's good looking he's
six foot four like he's talented he's
ambitious like there's no way he would
have just wanted to like in my mind I
don't think he would have wanted to like
settle down with anyone at that point
because he has like the world at his
fingertips and that's what women don't I
don't think modern women understand that
another thing people never talk about is
that younger men go quite well with
older women yeah so there you go no she
said young young woman older older men
synergize well with younger women and
you said the opposite yeah I'm saying
younger men also synergize other women
because if you're someone who likes
casual relationships right older women
are great less stress I see all these
guys chasing these young girls and I'm
looking at like you're not you don't
want a long travelership anyway you're
gonna get stressed out she needs
attention every five seconds it's gonna
be all this drama I think we're talking
about relationships here we're not
talking about just flings yeah that's
that's for fun yeah I'm talking about
for fun yeah yeah forget that it's
different but I thought you might as
well both be young like okay
yeah you're basing relationships on just
like having children and these times
you're basically you're wanting these
people to have children and then be
together forever
it is about having children
that's what a man get married if he
doesn't get kids out okay and this is
what I'm saying they had children
already then why would he get married
not 2022 yeah no I don't if we're making
about children if we were making about
children then I would say just pick
somebody that's genetically fit somebody
that is someone emotionally healed and
have a baby with them and then let them
live their life you live your life
together you can have a baby
why wouldn't you pick someone that just
wasn't damaged like I know I know a guy
that's dating because
and most people have trouble I know at
some level even if you've got both yeah
like it's so simple there's two times
there's two times there's two types
listen there's two types of
relationships you're gonna get like I
don't know why people are making it hard
you can either pick somebody who has the
end result already and fit in or you can
find somebody and journey with them and
if you have unfortunately and if you
haven't made the decision to Journey
with somebody in your teens you miss the
boat
if you reach a certain age because in
other parts of the world they make it
clear if you're over 30 and you're
unmarried without children China is like
in China
in the U.S it's like um they used to
have a term I can't remember leftovers
not even leftover it was like a maid is
like 26. that's what it used to be yeah
it's like uh there's some I mean they
wouldn't say that nowadays but but
you're at leftover women over 35. so
just accept it that if you've waited
this long and you haven't got what you
got you're gonna just take what you're
gonna get and if you're smart enough and
you're young and you know that what your
value is make smart Detroit smart
decisions now that's all it is you just
have to be real about it like I'm at a
certain age I haven't done certain
things by this age this is my reality
do you think it's a bit weird to give
women advice I'm not giving women I'm
giving women advice on how to get men
he's just it's just saying what it is
yeah it's not an advice like me saying
the sky is blue is not me advising
somebody that the sky is blue sky
like you know dating app data by 30 50
of your options are gone
30. like the the men that were attracted
to you at like at twenty fifty percent
okay let me jump I'm not I'm not even
done
and so you can't go to men and say you
should want this you should want this
they don't want it and if you weren't
smart enough to get with a guy in your
early 20s it is what it is you're
probably not going to get the men you
want and any man that he wants you is
probably going to be a Sim sorry it is
it is and it's it's okay
and remember this and as a man I'm more
likely to get the woman I actually
choose and want if we're not exceptions
to the rule where you kind of you know
you get girls early at an older age I
have to work my way up to a state is to
then pick a woman I want some dudes are
lucky we got we got the the luck of the
draw looking good being symmetrical
being you know appealing to women in my
in our age but for majority of men they
have to work their ass off to get to the
point to get the woman they want to let
him go no I was gonna say that on the
topic of what you were saying about how
we're giving advice to women I was going
to give the advice to men and I do think
like that's something that's missed out
quite a lot in these conversations
nowadays which is young guys if you plan
ahead and you want to have a focus on a
vision for yourself then
that's probably a good time that if you
do have something around you that's
actually right and pushing you forward
in the right direction maybe consider
that more than you would when you're
mostly your boys would that just jump
onto the next thing because I feel like
that kind of creates a pattern as well
within guys when I don't know I would
say like to me a lot of these red pool
guys they just sound like they [ __ ] a
lot oh because it's kind of like dude
it's in your power in it like oh women
don't do this then find someone who
doesn't it it's really that simple it's
really it's not that hard I like him
again just go find someone like like I
don't I don't walk around the club and
then complain that like oh these girls
are doing this yeah I'm not a fan of it
Alex but half of red pill is
self-improvement that's like half of it
it feels a lot like complaining there's
so many yeah because women aren't used
to being used to being complained about
ever like I'm sorry but women complain
about men all the time but all the time
so so if women have to hear what men
have to say and they don't like it sorry
I don't really feel bad for you with
like men have been hearing this [ __ ] for
years
we have a lot of male friends that um
would go through a long stage of the
whole phase and then they will realize
it's actually not fun the only reason
that it's fun is because I can actually
go back to my boys and say yo guess who
I slept with they didn't actually enjoy
it that much they actually would rather
settle down
with a really ugly fat chicken
honestly I don't know
it depends on the person it's all about
your catalog yeah that's what I was
gonna say I think it was what a girl to
settled down without the end but I I
know some guys that are very happy with
their rotation put it this way like one
thing I've noticed as well yeah like if
you like bump into like what they would
call a pretty hoe and she sees she sees
the girls that you slept with before and
she doesn't feel like they're on your
level you don't get access to that hoe
and I've seen that happen bad times uh
you stay with her you think you can come
to me yeah you look desperate now can I
say something can I just I think I I
think it's my responsibility as a woman
to praise good behavior okay when I see
it in a man Nemesis no I have issues
with you but I'll say something if men
were thinking more along the lines of
these two where they say actually sex is
not really what motivates me towards a
woman men would have much better luck
sex needs to go out the window more wait
let me copy out what I said right so you
like intellect I only
filtered women out sexually between ages
of like 8 19 18 and like 26. it's
something I've recently stopped doing
because I have
things are working out very well right
now and I no longer have the need to
prioritize that certain aspect of
relationship you know you reach a
certain age so I do think it's phases
right a young dude yeah dude do it
figure it out but you will get bored
a man will go through his whole life
build his career and old dudes why do
they call old dudes pervs because that's
what they're thinking about it because
they're still at it still okay that's a
sex addiction it's not desperate it's
not no right
you're selected listen you're not gonna
try and deny my my sexual hormones as a
male I am I'm an alpha I am a hunter and
that will never ever die
no because because let's be real let's
be real that's why that's why when you
said that you lost your virginity in uni
it was a shock over the bench because
most men are expected to be hunting from
as soon as they hit their rights of
Passage your balls dropped yet your
voice dropped yet because that's what we
know like let's not take that away from
us being men that's why women like men
that are like that that's why if he was
getting sex during that age group you
know what type of dude you had to be you
had to be confident you had to have
style you had these are things that
create us as status do you see what I'm
saying
she was smart enough to see his project
trajectory he knew right this guy's fit
he does what I like I'm a pick I'm a
choose she made a wise decision and he
made a wide decision by recognizing that
he needs to Value himself but I also
like I said I was seven years old when I
broke up with my first boyfriend because
he had bad grades yeah and then she said
all right if you're gonna have a bad
grades you're not gonna go you've got to
remember I have a good job you're not
gonna take care of my kids
but I understand what you're saying but
to close my point what what makes what
shows that she's a different kind of
woman is that she was willing to fight
for it because like she said she broke
up with her three times
okay but modern women just like we was
here on the other day like just the
other day should modern women compete
for men what was it unanimous
unanimously
yeah
it was it was we asked if modern women
should compete for a man and most women
said no I would not compete for a man I
said hell yeah isn't it natural
comeback isn't it just a nut sorry isn't
it just a natural thing automatically no
but I mean like without them so be the
center of his name
competition I was about to say without
them like actively subconsciously we're
always in competition because if we see
if we walk into a room as a group of
girls and we see a guy and he is the hot
one we're automatically hoping that well
not hoping but we would have made the
most effort to be there well of course
but I mean we're talking about these
women
um and so yeah no I think subconsciously
naturally women compete and I think as a
as a woman if you're not like willing to
like fight for your man and like
actually put in that effort to like
nurture that relationship and make it
really special like that's not the one
like I think a lot of modern women
nowadays they want to just sit on their
ass not do anything like and they expect
this guy to make black [ __ ] eight
figures and like be on his hands and
knees for her doing everything that I
like like doing
say is like you know everyone
um we live in a culture where it's very
replaceable and it's like oh if he can't
have me at my worst he can't have me he
shouldn't have me at my best so what
you're gonna be a moody [ __ ] all year
and then all of a sudden he's gonna like
just wait for that one day you're in a
good mood and a lot of modern women play
so much value on money and Status money
and stats isn't going to emotionally
fulfill you and make you happy you need
to find someone who has that ambition
that drive to make theirselves better to
make their self like someone with Talent
someone with could like I don't know
it's not all about money it's like not
impressive
yes
please don't cut the other guests off go
ahead no it's just saying that I my ex
and over 150 and it wasn't loving what
it was at moments and I put all the way
I was going to be is that the nine years
no that was after
we were both in the military together me
and my son's dad
um and so and I met him in Iraq and so
they my
point was that
like that money thing it doesn't make
you happy it was the most miserable
relationship for me personally that I've
ever been in like yeah we have money but
are we happy together no so like it's
like for me that that isn't like the
ultimate goal I call them dudes finances
that's why he wasn't financing me though
because I paid on my own bills I did
everything myself and I always have done
so it's not like he was financing me it
was just he looked like I started liking
it like I went to Posh and I drove out
with the Nissan Micra because the
package the outside of it wasn't what
the inside was saying so for me it isn't
the you know you can no I also wanted to
add on to it quickly because back to
that quickly the Britney Rena thing I
felt like loads of modern day women
they'll see Instagram girls be getting
Birkin bags and assume that's value but
I want to look at one situation
like there's a rapper called little baby
and he had a baby mama called Jada
weather and he gave a porn star that he
cheated on his girlfriend with fifteen
thousand dollars so that's the same
amount of money you can get a Birkin bag
with so you need to ask yourself what's
the value of a Birkin because to ask
people that are regular Joes of course
you see a 15 gram bag and think I want
that but if the mistress is also getting
the value of that bag that's equivalent
to both guys taking me on a date to I
don't know Gaucho and the beat [ __ ]
she's cheating on me with to Gauchos so
the truth is money is not I feel like
money to an extent does build a
relationship in terms of like you know
providing and stuff but there's morals
there's emotional support there's so
much things like I feel like people's
just lost morals nowadays yeah how old
are you 19. yeah
um
at some point like women aren't going to
date a bomb for so long like I think
this sounds nice but like like at some
point there's a minimum amount of money
yeah yeah I'm saying this has a minimum
yeah yeah like yeah
we don't make six figures or anything
like that but it's like
it's an important at all is kind of like
no no no I didn't say that I feel like
like I said to a certain extent right
you need to provide and play your role
as a man but I feel like girls don't
even like 50k 80k is good but girls want
million figures like rap like half of
these high value men aren't even good
men like well and you wouldn't and a lot
of them like it's those you wouldn't be
happy in those circles it's not good
like if you're with a guy that's so out
of your league like the other girls are
going to be sizing you up and trying to
steal your man yeah and when you get old
he's leaving you yeah
but okay guys I'm tired so I'm gonna
wrap this up
um I'm gonna Read Super chess real quick
and then we're gonna do final thoughts
um guys like the video
um
thank you for the super chats they're
all going towards blessings monopod um
whoa jezek look at that Alpha Hunter who
doesn't have the balls to look into the
eyes when talking give me a break
um Sean Mora cinelva is unhinged and
intellectually bankrupt um Genesee I
like the married dude I find it funny
that he's in the middle of two extremes
the symphon is right right in the pimp
on his left
Black is Black is Panther Alex and
denalva look great together the simp and
the 304 the classic tale of simple
simping groveling and Desperation to
Macy Alex Bro toned down the simping
mobiz Pearl let's get it right
um let's get it right Mentor 304s but
not 304 makers Sebastian from what I
have heard it seems like a winning male
strategy is wholesome grooming as early
as legally possible also self growth in
game um wojinski let's hear you struggle
struggle to pronounce my name again I'm
sorry I'm sorry
um Elite gamer any self-respecting man
would only wife up girl who had a
history of long-term relationships any
girl who says I needed to heal or find
myself has been ran through and you're
going to fail miserably in a marriage I
think I read the rest also guys my
manager sent me
the new members that joined the show so
shout out to Bass pundit Justin Brian
nikesha McLean Sora Josie Thunderdome
um Ray Raiden Thunder of God snazzy
individual ninja Smokehouse and Elite
gamer 876 Welcome to our membership
tears
[Applause]
um okay final thoughts this way go
around and then do second row
um I feel like
women need to be real with themselves
and I feel like
they need to take accountability I feel
like in terms of men
I feel like men just need to man up
but that's pretty much all I have to say
um I think that women like well I'm
generalizing but I think most modern day
women need to stop thinking of their
self as the prize like you should both
be a prize to each other like you should
both be excited about each other just as
much as like
one another so yeah I think people need
to stop placing so much value on their
self when they're not actually
even emotionally like that depth full if
you get what I'm saying yeah
I don't have said enough I feel
um thanks for having me
thanks for coming
I would just say put less value on not
value but don't be as greedy I think a
lot of women and men I guess
woman will want uh six uh value six
figure man or whatever but um at the end
of the day if you're picking someone
like that and he's that he's he's gonna
feel like he's got the right and to
cheat on you so you're better off
in um in investing in someone and seeing
someone's potential if you're looking to
find a husband if you want to be a sad
joke be a side chick
yeah but other than that thanks for
having me
it's been a great time
you know I think
what we need to kind of get rid of is
like the whole mentality that we've kind
of adapted of everyone gets a trophy
because the fact that people like women
aren't able to admit to themselves that
they're competing with other women for
the guys that they want guys need to be
aware of that as well
and I think everyone just needs to know
that in the workplace your competing all
against each other in the end of the day
it's um but um yeah if everyone just
focuses on being the best not even the
best version of themselves but overdoing
the next person I think will start going
in a better actually
I think I think people need to stop
sugarcoating [ __ ] and say [ __ ] how it is
and if that is that and this is that if
your whole your whole your sin your simp
and
I'm saying that's how people need to
learn man because No One's Gonna Learn
man like as you're saying shame in that
shame and it's useful like you need that
so say how it is and stop trying to be
that person like oh yeah yeah no no no
like trying to be the soft person not
like say how it is this is reality
especially in this generation now
especially how the social medias and the
Internet is just what's going on this
you have to say how it is about because
people need to hear it
open conversation Alex you want to go
um okay three parting points first point
is
uh we want to be wary of taking on
feminine Behavior I think one I see a
lot in the red pill Community is
constantly talking about the type of
women that you don't want which is kind
of like reminds me of women who only
talk about the bad boys and XYZ it's
like bro if you don't like girls who
only want a six foot guy eight figures
guy and you're not that guy then why is
that why is that what you talk about in
it two be pragmatic be a [ __ ] man all
you man [ __ ] way too much I'm sick of
red pill now because I just hear
complaining Non-Stop
big up the passport Bros I rate those
guys get to I was in Spain they're
solution oriented damn I like me and
people who just move actually guys um
follow Austin Holloman if you guys want
to see um he moved from the U.S to
Brazil and he's having living his best
life those women are hot too they're
sorry listen and if you're if you're in
the UK I'm Spain Spain is down the road
Malaga all this they still got a lot of
traditional women in Spain if you're
looking for white feet they have the
right mindset you got no excuse to be
bitching on online about oh women this
and final point would be listen as much
as we all know the truth about you know
promiscuity and this and that I would
hope you're not the kind of guy who gets
off on like calling people hoes and you
think that does something we all know
what it is bro so I would say try and
remember to be nice in it because the
end of the day you're still dealing with
human beings and I think if we're just a
bit more respectful towards each other
we might we might actually you know get
on a bit better instead of having this
like you know
divide I see now and I I was previously
part of that's what I would say
to another
[Music]
made but that decision did something
beautiful to me he allowed me to look
back in hindsight and understand what
actually I did wrong and what other
people should do better to not be in the
situation that I was in so that is
simply pick somebody that likes you for
who you are and is willing to support
you and grow with you boys and girls
because you cannot just pick somebody
for what you want you need what you need
and that's somebody that is loving and
nurturing both ways you need a woman
that supports you men and women you need
a man that supports you and that's it
that's simple
all right
um what I'll say is on my final thoughts
is that
there's been an inflation of hoism
there's been an inflation of hoes but
there hasn't been a match of pimps to
match that inflation
though that's it there's a big
sympathetic yeah crazy sympathetic which
we're struggling from so it's it's more
deadly than kovic exactly right so
instead of instead of running from the
disease and trying to keep six feet away
from me you can run to Brazil and you
know and quarantine over there if you
want to go and quarantine elsewhere by
all means but if you've still got the
balls to fight the women that are in our
in our ring right now bro like like I
said there's been an increase of hoism
it needs to be an increase of pimpism to
put these ladies in check to put them
back on the track of wanting to be wives
because that's what pimps were there for
to remind women this ain't cool you
don't want to be out here on this corner
in the cold like like you know like the
Statue of Liberty you don't want to be
standing outside all day so go and be
your wife so if you need help on how to
be a pimp and you're struggling hold out
my Instagram
it was so nice today and if you want to
be if you're three or four and you want
to be a wife and if you think there's no
coming back there probably isn't
however
we're gonna try here at Jones pearly
things and just partly things you modern
women you at 304 sign up for wife school
and subscribe to um wife school with
pearl
um also seriously subscribe to my new
channel I'm gonna be inviting um
different show guests and we're gonna
react to things in my room or have like
little podcasts like I have a whole
reaction set up where it's like a little
less produced like blessing doesn't have
to be here for me to use it it'll be a
lot of fun maybe some freestyling you
never know but
he's got balls I heard him
um okay guys couple announcements before
we end the show um the first is that we
have two clips channels the first is
just pearly clips and the second is
Pearl daily
um the second is that we have our four
membership tiers the first you get to be
a part of the live chat shout out to the
seven or eight members We Got Tonight
the second is a part of our Discord and
our Vlogs you want to see me freestyle
sign up for that we're also gonna do a
penthouse tour I'm sorry I know I've
been promising that for a minute we're
gonna get to it I swear I don't even
want to give you guys a date because I'm
afraid we won't live up to it our third
our third tier um connect with me on
social media this means having access to
my inbox fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
um also guys um sign our follow my
Instagram just pearly things one follow
my Tick Tock justperlythings.5 and just
pearly things six
um DM the pregame show if you want to
come on the show a lot of guys will DM
me to asking to come on the show stop
I'm not gonna respond to you please
please stop asking me to come on the
show I have a recruiter that's on the
pregame show page I don't want to do it
anymore but a little advice to you of
your guy and you do want to come on the
show there's a lot of guys that want to
come on the best way to get on is to
bring women
um because again we have such a backlog
of guys that want to come on and it's a
little bit harder to recruit women so if
you want to come on I would say bring
women
um
thank you for the super chats oh we just
got one more
um let me read this before we end uh
poppy poop oh Poopy Puppy women can see
they're actually raid actual rating and
think average to below average men are
beneath them they leave cheat or get
bored and move on women hate settling
down with good men they know everyone is
destined to work sleep and pass with a
few things get over yourself
um okay thank you guys for watching and
we'll talk to you next time
[Applause]